no well what's your special bro and
you're like you started talking about
your dad
and i'm watching it going
uh i can't get sad man the [ __ ] had a
dad
hello everyone hola mis amigos
sporting paul
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg hi oh my
god
hey everybody this is producer grant
here just a reminder if you like the
show if you're enjoying the show please
like comment subscribe on any platform
you're checking it out on whether that's
on youtube whether that's apple podcast
spotify anything any engagement that we
have really really helps we all serve
the almighty algorithm these days and
any amount that you sort of interact
with the show in any way just really
helps us out helps us get cooler guests
for the show helps raise the profile for
the show helps give us more content for
you guys to enjoy so thanks again for
checking it out and please enjoy the
episode
you know you know in this business man
you could know somebody like
over 30 years and never really have sat
down to talk to them because you know
you're always in different places so you
want to introduce our guest comedian
willie barcena in the house
we've never sat down before and had a
conversation we actually did bro we
actually did many times
i remember you and i sitting down in um
san antonio they're not coming i don't
[ __ ] remember no no listen i don't i
remember this we sat down and we talked
and that matter of fact bro after that
you and i walked back to our hotel was
uh which was connected to the to the
mall
and i remember you bro we passed some
suits
and you looked at me and you go willy
man you know what i want in life man i
want to be able to walk into a store
like that and buy two suits man and not
even worry about it
i remember that's how long ago this was
brother it's all kind of yeah no we
talked we talked a few times man now he
owns a suit company yeah and i was
exactly but this was back
we asked you to [ __ ]
trap those kids
no i remember another time
you and this is back back before
all the pedals started with carlos and
all that stuff bro santana yeah yeah
so you and i were at at a party for uh
it was it was uh
uh ch chon uh chicha's birthday chicha's
birthday in san antonio that's right and
then we go to his room and smoke weed he
made that made of the the bong out of
the apple yeah yeah bro but it was you
you and carlos were trying to tell me
it was before myspace before my space
and you guys were telling me hey willie
you got you gotta um get people's emails
or people's addresses and postcards and
you gotta you gotta build a network and
i was like man [ __ ] you guys man you
know i said i told you guys uh you know
people are gonna find me
and it's funny
and years later you know years later
like through you know through all our
careers and everything i was like man i
should listen to these guys
but before myspace before myspace bro
you could use you
carlos and another cat you guys just
would put cards on tables and people
would give you their their address oh
yeah that's right and you guys would
collect they're at and send them you
guys this is way back in the day bro
anyways man um oh it's paul paul was
another one i know and i know the whole
appellate
[ __ ] that you guys
he and i have pedal no i don't know you
guys might know that i don't know you
guys do you guys i mean i've never seen
you guys on the show together you know
you know
no okay uh um
you know paul rodriguez
uh i've met paul rodriguez in
1979 he had just started [ __ ] i was in
ninth grade he was you know
i wish i was a ninth grader
but but uh
paul got hot faster in the early 80s
yeah with that sitcom
he did the tonight show johnny carson
did great do you ever see him on the uh
tonight show yes paul rodriguez yes he
had the mexican express card express
card
pulled out a knife
and then he had a great joke where he
was in the elevator
and uh
were there people talking
what was a joke he said they were in
there and he says to the people you
weren't in there
and i said hey this is america
speak spanish
and then he had the yeah and he also had
the uh the flying saucers yeah remember
that he would throw tortillas
there he's a regular [ __ ] chicano
gallagher huh
the uh
but uh um
i'll tell you this i've ever hardly ever
said this publicly
but me and my friend ernie
got rest to seoul
uh were at the comedy store one
monday night
and uh in the early 80s
and they said um and we're gonna bring
this guy up you know special guest paul
rodriguez goes up there
and people i think they know dc cab
or he had a ak pop but whatever he paul
was like on the up
and he goes up there and [ __ ] kills a
man in that in the side room the
original room where his home the
original room and [ __ ] just kills a
man it's killing everybody and uh when
we were leaving me and ernie we're
looking at each other and we're like man
this [ __ ] guy is good man it's like
imagine by the time i get that good that
dude's gonna probably be that much
better
but
he never got
never got that much better because i
don't think he really worked he kind of
he kind of paul
would say he would wing it he'd walk out
there and just how he was feeling
he would just kind of wing it and that's
you know kind of hit and miss you know
so i think you know
preparation man in this business you
need to be more hits than miss so i i
just think he he ran into a little thing
where he was trying to get by on like
attitude
but you really need to be better
prepared yeah for anything yeah yeah so
no
i did a show with him about
i know two years ago i did it we did a
theater
and
this whole thing came up about the
latinos you know because back then man
it was it was paul was working and you
were the only headliner bro and because
carlos me and co i don't know if you
noticed me carlos and two other young
comedians went to go see him when when
he when you did our senior hall man oh
we were there i don't know i don't even
know if you [ __ ] know no i didn't
know that but we were like we're like
little baby comics you know and like
we're looking at someone who like it's
one of us you know one of our guys is is
in you know it's like a mob thing you
know hey that's one of our guys he's in
yeah and we're all up there man
and uh and then we all went to go to
diner after it was me carlos and and uh
uh i think jeff garcia was with us and
jeff garcia was like 17 18. but then
anyways i i brought this up to to paul
when when and uh two years ago and i
said yeah man it was you
and it was george i go
and i felt that
for me
we could have been more of
of a group like like the negros do bro
yep the black dudes i came up with south
central at the comedy club and i used to
see the way they came faison love dl
hughley all these guys they were all
young comics man
a pierre
um man
and chris tucker who back in the day i
used to give him a ride so tell
everybody where that club was because
crenshaw on 43rd so back then
there was a few clubs in in uh
in uh uh in that area at marla's memory
lane there was a couple other ones uh
what was that which one was that what
you guys went to do you remember
um there was this
this guy named brown something brown and
and he wrote for uh for
brown no no no no no no no j anthony
brown j anthony brown he had he had a
club yeah and his was on crenshaw the
one that i'm talking about was on
crenshaw on 43rd bro but anyways i see
the black guys out they would pull for
each other they would be in the green
room uh upstairs at the com
and i wanted to create that back then
you know i want i wanted to get us like
that but man
we just we just won't you know and
and i i brought that up with uh with
with paul
and you know paul's emotional bronzer if
you know that about him
super emotional dude man super like
people that hang hang out with him a
little you know he'll he started tearing
up man and he's like man willie
me he goes me and george we should have
helped the young cats more we we should
anyways man there's him you know
obviously man you know drinking a little
bit
yeah do you did you find that amongst
detectives were like were detectives
territorial where chicano detectives
hung out or white detectives hung out
with each other african-american
community uh uh detectives those that
liked mexicans didn't matter you know
there was no the mexican didn't give a
[ __ ] who they hung out with there were
some guys that just didn't like mexican
didn't hang out with them but they all
helped each other out
it wasn't uh there was no racism within
the police department no no we they're
come on
the 70s and 60s there was no no time
where
there was ever a conflict
now when you look back at things
and when you realize that they just
celebrated their 100th anniversary in
homicide bureau
and i went to homicide bureau in 1981
and then i went back as a lieutenant in
uh
2004
when i went back
i was the first latino above the rank of
sergeant
to homicide bureau at that time
you know it had just never been done so
why is somebody going to try and
convince me that there was never another
latino worthy of being a lieutenant
girl so i had all these things so there
are a few things like that but
and at that time if you looked at the
department most of the executives were
all
wide-angle saxons you know they were all
there so was there in somebody's mind
but in the working swine at our level
i didn't see it you know you didn't see
anybody having having an issue with
having a a partner of color no that they
wouldn't they wouldn't perceive that
that maybe that guy was not of the same
caliber because he might have been uh a
white uh
sheriff and he was wants to buddy up or
partner with another white sheriff i
never saw maybe just because i was
confident in what i was you believe him
i was saying one guy out of i mean i'm
glad that it was you you know it's
better than nothing
it's like look i'll give you an example
there's there's a compliment right there
hey better than nothing
no you look they didn't believe me in
the nightstalkers please yeah did you
know that
yeah yeah i found out i bought him
through this so they didn't yeah they
didn't believe me then
and it was okay let's say let's say what
it is so
serial killer on the loose back then
in in in your investigations you started
to say this has to be
the same person
there's no way that this is two or three
guys or two guys doing it with one you
said
this one person one guy and and they
didn't believe you they didn't believe
you they made fun of you and they
bad-mouthed you
having the amount of understanding i did
it was easy not to believe me though
because nobody in criminal history
had ever done what this guy was doing
this is the first time in criminal
history
so it was easy not to believe me
i i don't
fault the guys for not believing me i
pissed off with the guys that made fun
of me and called me names said i was a
young public kind of did they call you
bro oh they call me a [ __ ] i'm
just a young hunk trying to make a name
for them
i won't no they didn't call me so they
couldn't say mo
wrong but [ __ ] incestual
so i i walk out of monterey park police
when i had a friend over there every
time you walk out they [ __ ] you to
death yeah because they think you're
full of [ __ ] and a young punk and this
uh so it it didn't matter i had it you
know i'd move forward i had a job yeah
but
what i was getting at was
that we weren't doing
what the blacks were doing back then and
which was working together you know and
i don't know if you see something you'll
never know bro uh is that i did the
tonight show
uh and i and your show hadn't been out
yet on abc it hadn't come out yet
and this uh this is how i was man i told
i i told jay jay man there's a lot of
latinos out there that should be on your
show obviously i mentioned you man but i
was still trying to pull people in what
i barely got my toes in right do you
know what i mean and i and i and and i
think i told you i think me and you
spoke about this do you remember you
remember not bro i thought i wasn't a
fan of my but no but do you remember me
telling you
yeah i i i had told you bro like hey man
i i uh
i i put your name out there man and i i
don't know and i said i don't know what
it is i don't know if you guys don't get
along or what but i put your name out
there to be on the show okay did you
ever call him remember that did you ever
call him
did i ever call jaylen yeah
about what about the tonight shows
did you no no
okay all right bro why did he say i
called him no i don't know i i you know
cheese must fly so i thought did he i
don't know no no i never no this is okay
i never called him all right all right
um you did the tonight show 10 times
yeah which is pretty amazing oh wow i
mean amazing yeah that's great but on
all with jay leno oh jay i actually
they offer i got offered to do letterman
but you know letterman and and leno had
this thing yeah and i i knew about it it
was it was even before the movie came
out that there was that movie about
their right their competition but i just
felt loyalty to to jay you know i'm
you know i'm just a loyal dude bro and i
i had said i passed on it and that and i
told jay hey man i got offered i just
want to let you know man that i got
offered uh uh letterman but i'm passing
it up because i want to do your show and
then he was you know he was appreciative
he was
he was always a good dude
to me bro you know me actually
me and you bro we had some
some like stories that parallel that you
don't even know about bro like you had
when you when you got your sitcom with
abc yeah i had a deal with them at the
same time for my sitcom at abc at abc
and when you got picked up
i got dropped
you know i mean which is which is hot i
don't know how far did you get into that
did you did you shoot the pilot no no no
we we we got a a writer we wrote the
script and then we're going to the next
level and then i read remember back then
there they were that the magazine
variety we got 711 you can see like oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i remember when
we're reading it where oh george lopez
gets picked up and and then uh but the
day before they had dropped me my agent
had called me and said hey yeah
i mean you know if you're talking about
like helping other people they didn't
that you know they should no no this is
my point bro this is my point and when i
was talking to paul about like
how we are with each other yeah i said
bro this is what hollywood does to
latinos and i try to explain it to paul
and i'm going to tell you tell me i want
to get your take on it all right and it
and i believe that in hollywood man
we're not
we're not bad guys man people aren't
trying to
uh uh uh purposely screw
each other you know [ __ ] each other's
career what it is is hollywood gives you
gives the latinos a sliver of the steak
a sliver
all right and they throw it in there and
they get all these lions all right
[ __ ] eat
so that's everybody we're [ __ ]
chomping on each other trying to get
that sliver man you know
so i think that's to me that's one of
the reasons when i was telling paul i i
said hey bro yeah i think this is it
it's not intentional it's it's you you
it's it's almost like
a lot of latinos were put in that
position right where you're going to
[ __ ] fight to get that a bite a taste
and then you know the guys
look at this body
i got the bite but but uh but what's
your what's your view on them uh um
yeah i mean it's true i think it's it's
hard for everybody but i think it's
harder for latinos like um
you had
you had a uh well you you had a deal
there right yeah did jay leno have a did
you and jay leno have a deal i had a
deal with leno man and we we uh we got
this writer
and
a top-notch writer but i'm not gonna
mention his name no need to you know
drag his name in the mud but but um did
he did he write other shows with a show
runner or right no no no he he wrote for
a pretty pretty big show at the time
yeah and he got a lot of money i know i
know what you know jay told me man you
know what what they paid this cat
and
i was suppose you know your writers i'm
sure when you did your show you and your
writers would go and eat and hang out
maybe drink beer am i right or wrong or
no no that was no wrong yeah okay well
not wrong but we didn't do that you guys
didn't hang out no no because usually
that's what happens
a writer will hang out with the talent
to get to know their soul a little bit
so anyways this this jay try to manifest
that where he goes hey man go out with
the writer he set up a lunch
we had lunch
and all i all i knew was about him
like about you know
all i knew was like what he did what
he's done
came from new york started writing and
he went to nyu i heard all i mean he had
just bought a house
and man we were done with dinner and
this [ __ ] guy didn't ask
and this is where i'll give jay his his
props to man
okay so six months six months later we
got the script i get it you know and
then he gets it and then uh and then jay
calls me and goes willie
i read it bro it was horrible man
everything was like uh pinatas and
tortillas and like like
there was nothing tell your big girl
hungry yeah yeah yeah bro it was
we were like the car okay here it was it
was people laughing
at us not with us yeah you know what was
the premise of it though the premise was
actually the jay's job what jay did
before he became a comedian which he
worked at a dealership and he was the
guy that could talk to the salesman and
and and the guys in the in the uh
department yeah yeah the the team
yeah so he was the in-between guy and
that's what he did before he became a
comedian so he says i see you as that
guy but you know what i like that
already like you have to have an idea so
you have a place like a car place
right
the people go in there you see different
customers the salesmen and the guys in
between so he can come and be in the
offices and then he can be with the
mechanics and you got a little bit of
the yin and yang yeah
yeah i get it i mean i get yeah but the
guy the guy who who wrote it man it was
horrible man it was
the guy had no
he was brainless basically yeah it was
like uh you know it was more buffooning
than than than when they buffooned an
italian and a sitcom you know yeah
italian's always a dumb guy yeah it was
like way more than that and i and then
anyways jay goes really i can't i can't
produce this man any and then you know
he just said man i apologize
i gave it my all you know i know hey i
don't want to do this either man i don't
i don't want to do the script and then
we just you know
kind of we let that go but i continued i
think i think i still had another three
times with him on the on the tonight
show
but uh
and where did you meet him when he first
saw you and and at the comedy match
because that's a big that's a big deal
man to do one show
ten times over especially the tonight
show
it was that wasn't it was a big time
yeah but it was i mean one one thing uh
he saw me at the at the club and i was
leaving i was going home i worked a
five-minute set that i was
actually working on for another show you
know i was like mtv kamikaze or
something you know remember those shows
there was like a bunch of them vh1
spotlight right uh i was working for
five you know working a five minute set
and and and jimmy uh is it jimmy brogan
yeah jimmy broker jimmy brown right
jimmy like right kind of ran up to me
when i was leaving he goes hey because
jay wants to talk to you and i go you
know you're a kid man you're a comedian
you're you're i was like
jay leno yeah so like you know i'm only
used to seeing this guy's face on
television
doing a tonight show i go there and he's
eating his wings man he's like he's
gonna you know he looks up at me and
goes hey he goes hey kid
he goes i like you i like your comedy
and i go thank you sir you know i felt
like you know i probably got like an
uncle talking to me you know and goes uh
yeah um you know
i don't know man uh the next thing you
know
um
i was doing the show a month later man a
month later and it was uh it was a good
experience even just meeting i remember
when i went to his house
i mean i got to know him and mavis his
wife right i got to know them pretty
good man i remember i had a broken down
celica like tore up bro i mean it was
the ugliest thing you could i mean this
stick
the car itself was a [ __ ] blocker bro
yeah
like i am [ __ ] this guy
and and i remember going uh driving
through beverly hills looking for jay's
house man and i'm literally stopping
because i'm looking at remember back
there there's no phones none of that
[ __ ] bro you wrote it on a piece of
paper i'm going 12 21 12 21 and i'm
driving and i didn't know there was a
patrol car behind me just every time i
stopped he would stop and then all of a
sudden i go holy [ __ ] so i i went again
again and finally i go that's his house
and when i when i stopped that's when
the cop put the the strawberries and
everything man and then uh he's like uh
hey uh what are you doing uh checking
out these houses
so i sat i got i tried
said i have a friend a friend i go i go
who's your friend i said jay leno yeah
sure jayla jaylon's my friend too you
know he tells me like
he's my friend too i go no bro that's
his house right there as a matter of
fact i have his code right here because
you know if you have a code to talk to
the intercom and i go yeah let me see
let me see you call leno so i said yeah
i go
right and he's like hey willie you know
you got that squeaky mickey mouse voice
come on up so
i go and then the cops like
carl just shook his head and took off
man but but i got to know him at a
different level bro you know i got to
know him as a comic you're a good dude
or not he's a good dude bro tell the
truth no no no if he was a dick bro i
would tell you man i would tell you that
he was a good dude he does a lot of
things that man i know that he doesn't
like people knowing about a lot of
things that he donates a lot of money
and i know i'm probably gonna get [ __ ]
for this no no don't say anything don't
leave money to causes that that um
and he doesn't want people to know he's
just i'll do it but i don't want people
to know man you know very pro-police
yeah oh absolutely very bro yeah a lot
of [ __ ] my mornings are
[Laughter]
well hey bro i almost became a cop did
you ever
go to the academy and fill that
application and do all that no i booking
slip
yeah
did you want to be a police officer i
was in bro i was in with all my friends
um
like how did that
from
happen
bus stop or how do they how do you guys
find people
no it's uh
you go down right there commercials have
commercials
yeah the city well you know bro listen
back then
that's why i'm surprised that it wasn't
that you didn't want to be a cop because
we had beretta starsky and hutch the
rookies swat barnaby jones cannon
streets are simple
adam 12. adam 12. rockford files that
was a big one
dragnet
what else uh india policewoman
policewoman and then you had officer
love that black chick get christy love
so it was it was inundated it was like
we were programmed to think like that
was a cool thing to do you know and i'm
sure that's one adam 12 was the biggest
recruiter they had back then back when i
came was it one of your was that one of
your reasons again was it was no my
reason was i already knew i wanted to be
when i came out of the army a cop saved
me from the streets saved my life so
when i got out of the army i wanted to
become a cop and give back with that
gift what that guy gave to me and he
saved my life so i wanted to be able to
help some other kid
oh man yeah he had one of those
like feel-good stories man
yeah i just wanted chicks and i want to
carry a gun
honestly if i would have told you
because you got the interview would you
have pulled over chicks just to talk to
him probably bro i probably would have
been dirty
i'll be honest i would have been a dirty
cop bro i would have yeah
[Laughter]
no listen i know i would have justified
me pulling over a drug dealer and going
look [ __ ] um you got 10 grand
please i was like
look you got 10 grand right there you
know i could take you in it's gonna cost
you about five grand get your ass out
you're not gonna get this money back so
look man
um
fight for you fight for me get the [ __ ]
out of here you know that's not a police
officer what job is that that's gotta be
a vice
well yeah that'd be you know no but if
you pull somebody's device if you pull
somebody over and see it in the back
seat that that's in plain view yeah i
can say half of that is mine that's
better
that's where you and i differ that
should never cross my mind no you see
that as i'm saying man that's why i
didn't become a cop
why because if you say it did they pull
you pull you in
that's just the way i felt you know
i'm mad enough to stand up for what i
believe is right i never had the urge to
get never
it was one of the questions they asked
you in the interview
yeah they asked one of the questions
they asked me would you be putting that
in your mother if you're trapped if you
stopped your mother in a traffic shop
would you give her a ticket
that's what was the right answer
i wouldn't know what she did my mom
didn't drive so i didn't give a [ __ ]
i didn't drive no no
all white moms drove the mexican boys
did your mom drive she drove man
she
yeah i'm on drove me all right so anyway
so stick to the cops so then you guys go
to where you where'd you go apply a city
hall city hall bro and that anyway and i
remember
when they when they ask you the question
it's it's a civilian somebody from the
city and a police official
i went with the chairs oh you weren't
serious it was it was all deputies in
there and there was no okay no no
there's somebody
and then they shoot questions at you
just you just you sit there man with
your suit with your polyester suit and
and and i remember one of the questions
was uh if you were working uh there was
a robbery and you were in there with
your partner
and they broke a vending machine and
there was uh
some coins on the floor and you saw your
partner pick up
a quarter and put it in his pocket would
you say anything
okay let's say would you
i mean i know what the answer is
supposed to be
you know you see you don't even know you
just got to go in there yeah i could
fire this [ __ ] for a quarter no no yeah
okay what i what i said my answer when i
was 21 years old when i answered this i
said i would pull him aside and i said
look bro a quarter is no big deal if
next time just ask me
you don't have to do that that's what i
told the
in the interview
and and i s and and and they said so you
wouldn't report it
i said no i wouldn't report that i
wouldn't report a quarter i would have
talked with them and then then they
start then they start getting tricky
would you report a dollar yeah would you
report ten dollars
where does it stop so we know there's a
line yeah
anyways man there's all these don't they
don't they say like if you if somebody
put a hundred dollars in your locker
would you keep it i think that's one of
the tests in new york or something like
the cops
the cops um
at least what's that american gangster
the game they have some money there in
the thing and if you take it you're in
and if you don't take it you're not in
you know and i think russell crowe
he didn't take it yeah he didn't take it
so okay so then so then and then i was
in brother and then you go through you
can take the physical agility and it's
funny because when you're there it's
surreal because i remember seeing this
thing on charlie's angels you know
the entrance yeah
you know it was and you do the physical
you know
you jump a fence you had the t-shirt
your name stenciled no not yet no you're
just in your ring
that's when you're in there bro yeah you
carry this dummy you got to drag this
dummy and then uh what else you do you
have to drag a dummy yeah yeah you have
to do all this stuff and then you so you
you you know you pass that and then they
interview your neighbors they interview
your neighbors and they ask about you
and then they interview jobs that you
used to work at and i i just worked for
the broadway man i started shoplifters
so
it was kind of oh so you're already kind
of in the middle yeah you wanted to be
in no bro but i just wanted to meet
chicks bro you know what i mean it was
coming out
i was 20 years old all the hot chicks
working i remember i spent my whole day
i i remember one time the guy who was in
charge of all the broadways you know
which is a store like macy's today right
yeah yeah so it was uh the guy who that
was and the ex-sheriff by the way who
that's a lot of them do that when they
retire man he handled like six stores
and he called me in when time goes willy
man i got to tell you you have the worst
arrest record of anybody
i remember him telling me that and i and
all i know sir it's just that uh you
know they're not i don't know what it is
i had to come on you know i like tap
dance my way out of that [ __ ] you know i
was like yeah you know when i'm here
they're not stealing man you know i
don't know what it is but i'm too
intimidating i'm too good at this no the
truth of the matter man i used to see
like there were a girl in like the the
you know the certain department the shoe
department you know hot jig and i'd be
like what's up lisa and they're like and
they're like you know that's a nice
dress you know and then and i'm looking
and then
you know and so that's all i did all out
there was like so so we're doing high
school you know like right i know the
store is getting stolen but were you in
were you undercover or i was on the
cover
but so anyways bro so i got my letters i
was happy i got my letters with lapd and
and you passed and i i scored
an 88 or i'm either i'm confused where
it was 88 or 91 bro that for uh the oral
because that's probably 91. yeah and i i
did anyways uh why you say probably 91.
because at that time there were a bunch
of applicants going in if you didn't
make at least 90. yeah
yeah yeah that was you still passed but
you weren't going to be accepted unless
you were out
yeah you had to score high i didn't know
that yeah yeah no that's true and um so
i went to go party man a quiet canyon uh
you know back in the in the first the
party days did you ever go now you were
married already i was married already
yeah yeah yeah
i've been there but i was married i was
a spot that was a swap bro so i remember
i was there with some buddies of mine
which they all became cops i'm two of
them wow two of my buddies just retired
um
and uh anyways man i was add up bro i
was a stereotypical la kid man i had the
1958 drag top uh ragtop uh bug you know
lower yeah you know
with the blasting expose you right now
yeah yeah with the duck tail back here
the disco duct tape
so i remember
you know i got pulled over man by uh chp
and i got arrested and that was it bro
and that was it man
for dui for dui yeah and then they tell
you you didn't tell me i'm trying to bro
i had my paperwork right here i showed
him everything to the ch mini goes yeah
that's nice you can try again in five
years that's what you told me that's
nice is that what it is i don't know how
long it is yeah but he said you can try
again in five years
i know they make you wait
i don't know
there was a magic year
but they want you to stay out of trouble
for x amount because if they okay they
say two years and they bring you in and
then two and a half years you know six
months later you get arrested dui again
so they want to make sure that it's not
an issue
especially especially with booze is that
what kept you out yeah yeah that was it
yeah and then i got it so you were
planning to go i was going to be that
was all i ever wanted to be you know
because of the he had already accepted
yeah he was already accepted he had an
academy date yeah
he was accepted you're across the finish
line so
so okay all he had a dude
stay sober coming on but no no
uh yeah ah and that was it huh yeah man
um interesting
let me see um
so we all [ __ ] up or you were just on
the line i was i was
zero point zero nine
zero point what point zero one zero
eight is point zero eight is legally
drawing point zero nine what was your
name
no no they yeah
it was funny it was funny because i was
all discord out man and i went into uh i
mean you know you go to club you're
[ __ ] disco you got your cologne
and um i remember they took me they took
me to
um
what is it uh
no no and then they take you to process
you to uh the county jail irc yeah and i
remember i was sitting there i was
handcuffed in there and i heard all my
friends all my friends told me man
willie um if you ever go to jail bro you
just you gotta hit somebody first
[Laughter]
don't ever he goes even if you lose you
gotta hit first and uh it goes because
you'll be their [ __ ] for the rest is
like time you're there and in my head
i'm thinking oh man i'm gonna be here a
long [ __ ] time you know i you don't
know i mean i hadn't gone to jail you
know that you've never had any run-ins
in the book no of course not because you
were on your way to being a cop yeah i
mean i did bad [ __ ] but i never got
caught right
and it's funny because i used to rush
shoplifters and that was a great
shoplifting myself
so i felt like a hypocrite you know
that's why i would let a lot of these
where did you go what were things that
you could take levi's i would always
take levi's and lightning bolt shirts
because those lightning light remember
lightning bolt and quick silver oh yeah
like the pull over the polos yeah the
polos i'm still uh the ralph lauren how
did you [ __ ] steal jeans oh bro it's
uh you take sweats you go to the store
and you wear baggy sweats and then you
go in there and you get levi's
and then you put the sweats on top and
you just you know act normal anyway that
was that was my move
that was my go-to
bro i didn't have any money man
when you go to high school bro
kids are watching you if you don't know
what if you wear them if you wear the
same shirt twice bro they're like oh
look at this poor [ __ ] yeah you
know so i i was like uh did you only
steal around back to school or all the
whole year no back to school bro
no you never shopped it did ever yeah
all right
no i never got caught bro i was good you
know
i stole the car never got caught you
know we took a guillo one time you know
the guilds yeah
oh you were in the bugs huh yeah yeah we
uh i
we um broke into some houses and never
got caught i was like 16 15. did you
know that you're the [ __ ] serpent or
the statue of limitations on these like
am i glad they didn't make it brother
hey all my buddies got in bro they're
the same my mornings brother they did
the same [ __ ] i did
so i tell them that now now that they're
retired because they have kids you know
and i'll be like your daddy used to
shoplift and they're like
but you didn't go to the service or
anything right no bro no no and then
when i was all depressed man i was you
know
a buddy of mine when i woke up there was
a big letter that he wrote and i guess
you know when you're and you're drunk
you're saying [ __ ] that that you just
you know you're in another zone
and then he goes hey willie man you're
talking about killing yourself because
man you should stop that you should be a
comedian because you're always a [ __ ]
talker and that's that letter is one
that got me go to the comedy store which
i think one thing you and i have in
common and i might be wrong man you you
got past they didn't uh what was her
name mitzi never passed you at the store
no she never passed me either bro yeah
and and where's take what did she say to
you well i told her
i told her because they were having
auditions for the
for uh and and listen i regret it now
i'm older right i mean obviously you
look at your life and things you could
have done different
that that's one of them how old were you
at the time you were doing this 24 20 24
because yeah about 24.
no more than 24 man and she they they
would have um mitzi short would show up
at the comedy store and sit in the back
with a
and then always some ass kisser next
year yep some guy that [ __ ] licked
balls man would always be next year yep
and uh and and i remember uh there was a
flyer and and mitzi says we're looking
for
like specifically i'm looking for latino
comedians and i was pumped up man i was
like oh hell yeah latino community
looking for so i get there
and uh and she has us upstairs in the
belly room with no audience with no
audience and just her
and it was me gilbert esquivel johnny
sanchez carlos oscar a bunch of us so
that's why the story can
it can be verified you know i was up
there and i was telling my joke like
this with no audience and i just stopped
man in the middle of the set and i said
and
like i said i would you know i'm not
proud of not you know proud of it but i
said
hey you [ __ ] [ __ ] i said how the
[ __ ] could you do that to us how the
[ __ ] you have the latinos up here with
no audience but the blacks and the
whites and everybody else gets the
audience what you have is up here like
[ __ ] animals i said [ __ ] you and i
had the mic and i threw it and i
remember the valley room you would come
down
and i could hear it loud i heard her
loud who the [ __ ] is that like that
right yeah yeah i [ __ ] i ran back up
and i said my name is willy barcena you
[ __ ] and don't you ever [ __ ] forget
it and she never did bro because i never
was allowed to play there
my agent tried to get me in and go what
the [ __ ] did you do there willie i was a
long time ago man you know but uh that
was my experience it was kind of hard
not to crack over there man it was tough
yeah tough to get in when she was around
because she looked that you had to get
past her yeah yeah well well the guy who
goes she's still alive
no no no the guy who got passed was uh
mancia remember yeah yeah he got but was
he her driver
or he was a doorman no quinn quinn guy
named quinn something quitting something
but wasn't he monsieur the doorman or
something he could have been i don't
know but that's what i'm talking about
okay
when when and i go back to this what we
were talking about earlier bro uh is is
when when a um
like chris tucker when he did death jam
yeah i remember man all the comedians
were showing them
calling him everything when i did the
tonight show
not one not one latino comedian not one
call me up and congratulate me not one
you know like hey congratulations we're
proud of you me mother bro and i was
like all right [ __ ] it that's what
uh you know i remember trying to build
the [ __ ]
you know i i had a room in east l.a
where i had felipe right i remember
fluffy and the fluffy you know listen
i know like i don't know if his memory
uh uh works against him or what but
the way he did comedy i did comedy at
fluffy's college when he was in long
beach and he came up to me a little
gordito like hey i want to do comedy
right now yeah i do this room in
montebello which used to get packed man
was that one it was they changed the
name every year they killed somebody
every every year
um it was um
no it was uh i turned on what are your
boulevards tortillas it was called
tortillas after 60. no yeah yeah
it's called tortillas it had several
names bro
and um anyways i remember it was a
restaurant right it was a restaurant
that they would do they would do comedy
man and i i i uh
i remember i would i was like a tough
coach bro i coached
comedians the way i coach baseball by
the way that's my son back there he can
tell you
he
yeah he played division two college bro
he was a shortstop third baseman pitcher
in college did you go to school in san
francisco
yeah what happened
no but i was no he just got just
graduated
so i he can tell you i was a mean
[ __ ] bro i would like that
he's nodding his head yes you know no
how would you say no no but i catch the
ball [ __ ] okay so
so it would be a coach part of you would
be even coach to comedians you found a
lot of guys yeah yeah bro and i know i
heard feelings and i remember uh fluffy
could go on stage and grab the mic and
pull it and goes let me get this out the
way so you can see me and i say bro stop
doing that [ __ ] i go
uh louie anderson that's that's his bit
i go don't [ __ ] do that i remember
this kid was so soft bro that he
it hurt his feelings yep and and every
time i would talk to him like that he
was soft man and i and i could see man
see
i came from dysfunction
i came from everything was like hey
[ __ ] i just negativity yeah so
my teaching process
although i had the same goal as a guy
that's going to teach psychologically
yeah but i was a dick
but did you did you did you want to be a
teacher did you want to be a
mentor no i wanted all of us to get
better right i just wanted us to get
better bro because there was no there
was no group i remember doing i rented
carlos and charlie's i still have the
flyers 1993 and and it cost me for me
that was a lot of money right but and i
had luke torres there i had all these
guys man and i i i want to do a latino
night and then uh and bro we only had
eight people right so and we're charging
five dollars so i made like 40 bucks and
i told each comedian was gonna get paid
200 right and that was a lot for the for
us back then okay so a lot now every
community
every comedian was cool bro every
comedian goes willy don't worry about it
you don't have to pay me the only one
who [ __ ] was that drilled me was uh
with mencia monsieur goes look bro
you're mad at your word i say i'm out of
my word he said 200 where's my 200. he
goes i'm not leaving tiger my 200. so i
had i i literally i remember i had a
girlfriend there at the time i had to
borrow money from her you know and i
said oh you and you paid
but that was always carlos man carlos
was the only one i mean listen
i know i know he's on his on this wave
of of redemption right he's he's
clearing like what happened to him you
know he got punished right for what he
used to do we all know what he did yeah
right
i mean he'll never get a nickel out of
me now
but get by the redemption like he's
trying to uh what's he trying to do well
i think he i think i think he he knows
in some ways he did he did some things
he shouldn't have done as a comedian and
we know what that is i mean joe rogan
exposed it right you know but to me like
i i had him at my house about
seven months ago and i invited him
another communion goes you know what you
should call carlos bro you know
and i i think
at that time the reason i invited him
and you're here and i think you would
like your opinion on this i think the
punishment should fit the crime so yeah
he did something bad but we're going on
two decades now that that that people
are longer longer that that people are
going like all right you stole you
[ __ ] all right it's enough man
at one point you gotta say okay you did
your time you know because you know it
was i mean [ __ ] they buried them on
south park remember that yeah oh that
was [ __ ] horrible yeah when i saw
that i was like oh [ __ ]
was that the fish sticks one yeah yeah
uh that was kanye well yeah yeah same
one
but um
why did that guy feel like he had to use
things that weren't his
uh
why did i
feel that i feel man
that
in like in the regular streets you got
guys who steal you know what i mean you
guys really rob
and in our comedy world there's also
those personalities man and i and i feel
i don't listen man i'm not in the guys i
don't know i can't talk for him i can
only tell you what i think and i know he
has 10 brothers and sisters and grew up
in the projects and i think one of the
things that he
hated the most was being poor and so i
could connect with that man because
i know
what it's like to miss meals bro you
know i know i know what it's like to go
to bed hungry right and that's one of
the reasons i always wanted to help
other cats out man you know
don't look at me i don't know what it's
like to go to bed i don't think you know
it's funny he's asking me questions when
i first got here they asked me about hey
willie did you play baseball did you do
no bro uh i i we didn't have any money
and so
when these guys when me
my other boy i got an old boy that's a
year and a half older than him they were
both actually played with steve garvey's
son
uh his his my was he good yeah
oh yeah yeah he played with ryan played
ryan ryan got drafted by the by i think
it was the rockies but we also played
with uh lenny dykstra's kid right one of
his kids was on our travel team here let
me ask you a question the older son the
one that played with steve garvey's son
yeah one of his coach uh clembonia did
they ring a bell with you at all
no man we had a guy named mike spears
okay was our our guy man and a lot of
those guys got drafted man a lot of
those guys are number one guys in in the
nation but anyways man getting back but
did you play baseball growing up no no
no i play okay okay i did play
okay i'll tell you man
i like sports i'm gonna tell you how
much i like baseball
i had a i had a mother who was evil man
she's just
she's she's
she's just a bad person man
we never got along
to the day she died we didn't get along
she lied she's [ __ ] bullshitter she's
not a good person man i remember uh my
room i had to be home in sixth grade i
had to be home by three o'clock
by 3 30 i'm sorry 3 30 i had to be home
because she had to go to work so she had
to make sure that i was there
and i had signed myself up for little
league right right for baseball yeah for
park and rex not a little parking rex
and she had said she had told me no but
i forged her name
you know and parking rex you don't get a
uniform
you wear your pants but a t-shirt a
t-shirt yeah with a number on it yeah
yeah and and i remember she whipped the
[ __ ] out of me man one of these cordonas
man i got hit with one of the things
because i went to practice yeah
and she said
where were you i said i was a baseball
practice and she started whipping
right and you put your hands up and they
put your hands up the whip goes around
hits you in the face you know yeah so um
she said she better quit
bro do you know that i never missed the
practice man like she would [ __ ]
every it was i was almost routine like
clocking in you know like all right here
goes the ass whooping ex
wow i remember
yeah but i wanted to play and i i tried
to tell these cats like when they were
little you know i go man i didn't i
didn't have this opportunity you know
because i was i was immigrant bro i saw
oranges on state street when i came from
mexico i didn't even speak english man
it was uh english was it was hard for me
to pick up english because at the house
everybody was spanish right yeah and and
then i had an uncle that was if you try
to speak english he puts you down man
he's like oh i i see
you know like you [ __ ] bust your
balls instead of encouraging you he
would put you down man
so so anyways man but i think so so but
was your dad around you and your dad and
your mom that piece of [ __ ] bro he um
she he left uh and uh and juarez he took
off with some chick he met and so and he
never came back never he tried coming
back and being a dad for a day when i
was 16.
i got back from high school and i'm
walking he's in the living room
and then i see my mom she looks at me i
look at him like and i was 16 and i was
like i think i was 17. so [ __ ] you doing
here man and he goes he goes he said i
don't know what he said bro but i told
better get the [ __ ] out of here when i
come back i slammed the door
and i left and i came back i don't know
six seven hours later and he was gone
but that was my only uh but man you know
he's a piece of [ __ ] man he's a piece of
a human being
um i think it's i think it's um
man you know to have a family like that
and
to
want to start your life it puts you in a
bit of a [ __ ] you're like just
waiting for the next yeah or something
to take advantage over here the next
thing to happen right there's no way you
can [ __ ] be in peace
i'm just really
still kind of in shock
every not everyone i'll say a lot so
many comedians that i've met
have problems such as yourself you know
in childhood
parents
grandparent you know whatever it is but
they were traumatized as kids and now
they're doing comedy and they've come
out of it and
i'm i'm not glad that you went through
all the trauma i'm
happy for your community no but you know
what listen bro gil and here's the
people have asked me and i'm sure you've
gotten this too george where
where there's always that one person
that says man uh comedians you you guys
suffered a lot i said no [ __ ] we
all suffer every human being here if you
talk i don't care if a guy is a pilot i
don't care whatever they all have a
story
the you
bro gil you're one of the first guys i
meet that [ __ ] had this [ __ ]
situation where it was like you know you
skipped to disneyland with your dad you
know
i never went my wife made fun of me i
never went to disneyland as a kid never
not until i graduated from high school
and
because her family used to take her to
disneyland and i did so i didn't get
that right well you well you came from
your upbringing is a pretty stable which
is yeah
and that's not the norm no that's not
the norm in our society if it was the
norm we wouldn't have so many people on
on uh taking meds
you know so how long were your mom and
dad married
over 50 years before my dad passed away
oh wow and now i've been married 51. you
see what i mean
so you don't think it makes it difficult
being at home yeah stability having both
parents at home makes a huge difference
having to wear my sisters i had six
sisters no brothers having to wear
theirs hand-me-downs it was kind of
embarrassing sometimes
that's one of my jokes that was my first
tonight's show joke
i heard my sister's hand-me-downs
i had jeans with zippers in the back
you can play
okay carlos you're stealing my stuff
you stole my stuff yeah let's see oh
1995 bro
everybody remembers their their first
time on on the tonight show man 1995 man
you know
this guy you weren't even born yet
fabian
yeah
give me walk me through your first time
at the tonight show oh i was nervous as
[ __ ] bro what time did you get there
early and then yeah they sent a limo for
you so you like like you kind of make i
for me bro i was making the limo wait
just so my neighbors could see
and they're saying everything a little
loud
yeah okay i'm going to tonight's show
now you know
yeah it's tonight's show you know and
then and in the driver and
they take you and uh sylvester stallone
was a was the always the guest was the
guest yeah oh it's been that was yeah it
was i was here's a guy that i had
watching rocky in the rockies movies and
i was like
and he was a gentleman i'm sure you've
met him a lot of times bro
how was he with you man great great okay
yeah he was a gentleman with me
which i was happy man because half these
guys what did you think when you were a
kid like so you're a kid from the mario
right and then you're doing comedy and
then you go to the tonight show and then
you see sylvester stallone bro surreal
yeah
it was just weird it was almost like you
you pause
as you're talking you're pausing you
know you can't even act normal you got
you're going like you're talking and
you're going you're going yeah so
let's say you say oh hey good luck on
the show tonight really right and so and
then i'm just
yeah
yeah that's my first parents that's my
uh my first 1995 uh wow no that's
awesome man [ __ ] that's nice yeah man
and that's the only uh nice clothes i
had i think that's what i wore in my
interviews
for my police interviews man you know
you know sylvester is also very
pro-police
stallone i think most of the country is
great
i think
i think what happens is
is the people that hate the police get
uh get more attention
you know it's like it's like having kids
you know uh
the kid that's a piece of [ __ ] is the
one that everyone's gonna talk about
right you know so i think that's what it
is with we're pro police and people that
are anti-police because i think how did
police get on the hook for all the [ __ ]
that's that's going on in the streets
a few bad apples you know the news media
picks it up they burn them you know and
and so
it they don't burn them they tell the
truth you know and so but it gets a lot
of attention so it gets all the
naysayers see we've been telling you all
this time they're bad they're bad
they're bad but when you look at all the
cops that have been bad i don't care if
they're
the worst thing to me in law enforcement
is dirty cop because it makes us all
look bad right and so wait wait wait
that's a that's a
what's a dirty cop oh a cop that's
selling drugs adopted killing people
raping people okay okay okay
what about a guy that bus is a guy right
and uh
a bank robber
and uh
ten thousand dollars falls out of the
bag
mentioning ten thousand is this no
yeah he's a dirty cop yeah i i'd go into
crime scenes where there's you know a
drug rip-off so there's thousands of
dollars out there never once did i ever
think of picking up a dollar first when
there's money involved first thing you
did was give me a photographer in here
take a picture of this [ __ ] before i
start getting legs
you know so that never crossed my mind
and that's part of my upbringing because
the only thing my dad
embedded in this don't be a thief and
don't be a liar
so he succeeded on one of them you know
i never was a thief
but
uh don't lie and don't be
you know don't lie to me uh the reason i
i
that lesson is funny see you you your
dad taught you that you know who taught
me that the streets man yeah the streets
i i remember being uh in bowl heights i
used to live on on kingston near near
morengo and uh i remember being
eight years old on the state street park
i was walking home from school i used to
go to bridge bridge street school and i
remember i stole the yo-yo man from the
park and wrecked
you know you would back then you would
give something to the to the director
and then they hand you a ball right they
would like a basketball you got to give
them like your driver's license
or a jacket yeah oh yeah no no no
drivers are your kids
but i remember i remember i i saw a
yo-yo and i said oh [ __ ] because i got
mine whatever i had and i saw that yo-yo
i put it and i'm walking home and i was
on that on that uh the bridge
overlooking uh the 10 on state street
and that back that now it has a fence
yeah back then it had no fence it was
just like three feet yeah i remember
this cholo came running like to me it
was big because i was in third grade he
must have been in sixth grade but he was
you know third grade or sixth grade yeah
that's a big dude so emery goes hey
[ __ ]
get my yo-yo and i said nah man you
forgot my pockets what's this
[ __ ] he grabbed me by my shirt
and my ass and he hung half my body over
the thing and he goes you're gonna steal
[ __ ] you're gonna steal i go no
no bro i'm sorry holmes
i'm sorry i'm sorry spencer you know
what then he pointed back down
hey bro but that's the [ __ ] that i
learned like right away like all right
you can't be lying out here you know
because you ain't gonna make it you know
i mean that [ __ ] was real to me so he
went back there to try to get us his
yo-yo and they said oh man that dude
took it right there yeah she was chasing
you so that's where i learned about
about tell the truth and that's why so
many comedians
i get pissed off at the man because in
our business
there's a lot of weasels bro a lot of
guys who
who get in
not because of their talent because
their ability to kiss ass man because
there is some kissing ass
like we were talking about like the guy
who sits next to uh who was sitting next
to mitzi shore right there was always
one guy there i always say yeah puckered
up yeah and i was i was
never
a man
on a scale of one to ten
and and hollywood is is and and i had
too much street in me because
we it's called networking right right
it's called networking which you need
in in in the room it's still part of the
game
yeah you need networking and i always
felt like i took the streets mentality
to hollywood where it's like [ __ ] that
ain't kissing no one's ass right you
know because we we didn't call it
networking we called it kissing ass yeah
yeah so my whole thing was i didn't kiss
someone's ass
and and and that's it i'm gonna i'm
gonna uh you know do things uh right i'm
gonna do things right look in the
streets you do things right man and back
then what and back then
how did you think that somebody became
successful like you went you went and
did these shows right and then maybe
there would be somebody like you kept
going back you kept getting better
right as a stand-up you kept going back
you try to go to more different places
but then if you were in hollywood and
you went to the comedy store to the
improv somebody would be in the audience
and they would see you and they would
say hey man how would you like to do
this yeah yeah actually one of these
cats that i met out there uh uh said
that uh uh your buddy man said that i
knew him from we met in uh canada oh
jordy out there yeah he used to be a
comic yeah oh yeah so
man but i did a lot listen man
i i'm not going to blame
i got to put a lot of the blame on me
too bro because i did some stupid [ __ ]
i'm i i chased two hecklers out of the
laugh factory with the with the mics now
shut down
i don't know i was getting heckled and
then the guy said i don't mind if you
heckle me but the guy says something uh
racist you know especially back then
you see more latinos in in the clubs now
than he did when we first started oh
yeah you would look in the audience at
the ice house and you probably see three
latinos yes sir back then it wasn't like
it is not a lot of these young comics
they don't [ __ ] know man so
uh this guy said something and i said
all right bro that's pretty funny
don't you guys stop saying that [ __ ]
because see this mic stand and my style
has that big plate in the bottom i said
i'm gonna crack you with this thing man
shut the [ __ ] up so i started continuing
and then he said something and i jumped
off
and uh there was a little manager there
little filipino girl remember man
i think so yeah she's like a cute little
girl and
and believe it or not it was uh
mel garcia's birthday oh yeah garcia's
paul rodriguez is home dude right yeah
it was his birthday and paul was there
anyways man i jumped off stage and the
dudes just got off the chairs and went
out the side doors and i went after him
with the thing and then like bunch of
comedians and people were following
wait come on bro that story gets around
you [ __ ] and it's like a comedian
said really you didn't burn bridges he
goes you blew them up you know yeah
so i mean that's one of
many bro i remember chasing the the the
the club manager at club called go
bananas is in cleveland or connecticut
do you remember jupiter
gold bananas no cincinnati
yeah okay i remember the manager told me
the manager gave me the light i go all
right bro i see the light
and he goes um
and then he gave me the light again and
then you know you know how it was man
the only guy that i heard that would
take as many shots as me was you
i told you on stage because i i i would
hear i would get to a club and they
would say yeah george was man he took
like he took like 12 shots right so i'd
be like [ __ ] that i'm gonna take 13. you
know
you know what i thought nobody and
here's the thing you think nobody knows
like you think oh you get [ __ ] up one
night and you [ __ ] make an ass you
stay there you [ __ ] all along and you
throw up or some [ __ ] and you think wow
thank god nobody's gonna know that
everybody yeah he travels fast there's
no
[ __ ] secrets somewhere that club man
uh i told i asked the audience you guys
want me to leave and they were like no
and then i go all right i go and then so
the manager came in the light brothers
15 20 years ago
and i said i said bro give me the light
one more time i'm gonna shove that up
your ass and make your glowworm
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
and sure enough he came five minutes
i threw the mic on it i started chasing
them i chased them into the kitchen we
went in circles a little bit
you know i was pissed off bro and uh
you know and when i never got
to work bunch of those clubs again you
know that was kind of the end of that
but but but uh uh
you you threw a lot of ching [ __ ] on
a little bit bro where did the fighting
gene come from
i've been being abused bro i think my
mom yeah i think my mom hitting me like
a like a like an animal
um uh
because you know what there's
interesting things matt about willie
one that that i know is that
he would try to help young comedians
like tell them
how to get better how to be better
where they might have heard some stuff
and you know you need to do this and you
do that but also like you didn't take
any [ __ ] from if there was guys that
didn't take any [ __ ] he didn't take any
[ __ ] from anybody like nobody no but but
i never i didn't know about your
upbringing and you can see how
like somebody's just ready to go all the
time like you know you're just ready to
go like you expect something
not good to happen and somebody's
[ __ ] with what you do and you say hey
listen man [ __ ] relax all right take
this [ __ ] thing i'll [ __ ] shove up
your ass and he
comes doesn't it again it's like a
trigger right you just the trigger it's
a hair trigger you go often you know but
you know george i tell you i tell you
guys
when i had kids when i i i said
my whole thing was i didn't want them to
grow up like i did and he could tell you
my son's favorian here hey bro i hugged
you and i kissed you on the cheek many
times bro right you're in front of your
friends i didn't give a [ __ ] you know
because i think too much no it's all
good
because i didn't i didn't want that i
didn't want it to continue you know i
don't want that whole macho [ __ ] to
continue man because you know looking
back at if i look back if i could go
back and talk to me
you know i i'd probably give myself a
hug and say calm the [ __ ] down you know
it wasn't your fault you know everything
that happened to me i was always i had a
like a chip on my shoulder i was always
you know like
you know i don't know if it's you know i
think it's too easy to say it would be a
chip i think it's just
[ __ ] years of abuse and years of
mistreatment and years of disrespect by
your parents i mean your parents are the
people that are supposed to take care of
you they're supposed to know wonder
where you are they're supposed to ask
are you all right they're supposed to
feed you they're supposed to keep you
right not you know abuse you when you're
in the one [ __ ] place
that you should feel safe yeah that's
what it is you're in your [ __ ] house
man if you're getting abused in your own
house you're in in the room that you
watch [ __ ] cartoons that you could
see yourself getting [ __ ] choked or
thrown across the room or [ __ ]
slapped or hide under a chair so they
can stop [ __ ] hitting you with the
belt i mean that [ __ ] is awful for a kid
back
for anybody for a [ __ ] dog [ __ ]
anybody yeah but especially when you're
developing yeah
bro and then we had a
uh
uncle my my
my mom's uh
uh brother stay with us this
[ __ ] bro talk about okay okay
he's gonna be my role model right
[Music]
i had we had beds and his bed had bugs
he had bugs because you know he wouldn't
shower or whatever right so he had bed
bugs
but i remember him waking me up like a
eight o'clock like like at night man i
was about nine years old wakes me up and
goes hey go to that bed i go why he goes
just go to that bed i want your bed so i
go to this bed brian wake up with like a
thousand [ __ ]
nice
[ __ ] bro that's brilliant and a
[ __ ] bed bug is like a little chinchy
like a little [ __ ] pin prick and that
[ __ ] some blood he starts oh
think about that's the kind of role
model i have you know this [ __ ]
that's terrible
[ __ ]
[ __ ] lies
man
bro i i didn't have that the only thing
i didn't have is i never heard my dad
say i love you
really yeah i know he did but it was a
different you know upbringing you know
it was generation generation
generational gap absolutely the day
before he died i said and i had never
said said it to him uh i grabbed him
santa said i cleared the room he was in
the hospital
and i said dad i got to tell you
something and he said what's that i said
dad i love you
and he he put his hand on top of mine he
said son me too
well he didn't say it yeah i love you so
there is not a day
when my kids grew up i don't care if
they got in trouble if they got their
ass
nope there is not a day that if i'm
there that they don't hear me say i love
you yeah because i missed that for my
dad
no and and the next day i told my sister
i just wish my dad would have said i
love you and then she came in about a
half hour leashes you want to know what
your dad did you think he didn't love
you
she said look
in this metal box
and then the bank account in the metal
box
there was the deed to the house all the
insurance papers funeral arrangement
every important document he had and ten
thousand dollars in there just for my
mom to get started even though my mom
was working she had income just for
emergencies right now and it was all
wrapped up in a newspaper article
about me
about when i was helping to start an
orphanage in vietnam
he says that's how important you were
so i knew he loved me
he had just never said it
you know i was watching your other one
says it's netflix and and i saw this
tearful moment you had you know and i
think i think right
the [ __ ] opens the door and he goes to a
door and if it's open he starts cracking
he's happy
hey bro no it's so beautiful so i'm
watching i'm watching him i thought he
was gonna be locked
[Laughter]
no i was watching your special bro and
you're like you started talking about
your dad
and i'm i'm watching it going
uh i can't get sad man the [ __ ] had a
dad
like you had a daddy [ __ ]
it's hard not to have a dad all that
[ __ ] important thing your [ __ ]
mom's there
[ __ ] ladies
i got the guy got it i'm all right now i
want to walk here with you [ __ ] don't
walk in with me or at least don't
scratch your pedals
oh man my gran my mommy's just [ __ ]
ugh
she would be like this she would be like
we should walk in the room
all right she's walking over
what do you think what are you guys
watching [ __ ] right here
[Laughter]
that's not what we're watching is what
we're smelling uh
i mean just nasty man like you know what
i mean it's like but no but we don't you
don't have anything so
whatever [ __ ] [ __ ] dry skin that
[ __ ]
so you know you're poor so you don't
have any [ __ ] class or any you don't
know you don't have any like cool
further stuff that that [ __ ] is
uncoof
catch you with your finger
[ __ ]
your [ __ ]
they're not going to have any [ __ ]
class they're not going to go they're
not going to know what's right and
they're going to be [ __ ] they're mean
they're [ __ ] mean man they're mean to
kids junkyard dogs yeah that's that's
that's what i say man like when you say
like why why would i snap on people and
it's because you know the way we we grew
up man you know it's like that little
chihuahua you [ __ ] with them all the
time [ __ ] with them on one day just [ __ ]
it i'm in
you know yeah but then and then also bro
our business
our business of hollywood and then when
we were coming in there was they would
like like we talked earlier there's a
lot of racism man i remember when i uh
auditioned for uh and i'm sure he's
evolved as a human now but
jamie masada right at the lab factory i
remember and he's a [ __ ] immigrant
from another [ __ ] country so i get
out the stage i had written these jokes
these there were political jokes and i
get off the stage and uh remember
he gets comedians he takes them upstairs
and he gives them notes you remember
this it's like 92 93 and so i get up
there i'm waiting for
these these are jamie's notes to me
he goes hey i heard your jokes uh you
shouldn't do that political stuff you
should and this is exactly what he said
to me you should talk about stealing
hubcaps and things like that
you know that's what he told me that was
that was his and i was like
i was like all right
i'll take you know i'll take a note on
that oh
i left going [ __ ] that i'm gonna write
about that i was i was right but this
you know you you yeah bro i'm sure a lot
of you you got to have thick skin and i
don't care at what level you're at to to
be and stay in the game
in hollywood
and and be a a latino and i know that
you know blacks have their issues but
bro they're
they just did a study netflix did a
study
about uh cultures
blacks are over represented 17
on netflix over and we're under yeah
we're under we're under and they're over
a certain you know like what you see on
on netflix that's that's
it's like you know
beyond what we already have of black
people where do you think where do you
who's responsible for
um
[Music]
uh
the oversaturation of of specials like
they used to call it a special because
it was
it was special
so if somebody was
i mean it made sense somebody's going
hey i'm shooting a showtime special or
an hbo special comedy central special
when it was special and now
this
i mean everybody has one they shouldn't
even say special comedy performance
whatever the [ __ ] it is normal i don't
pay attention to them now because there
are so many
there's a special it's just another show
right but there's nothing special about
it different than anybody else so just
because it says special now is not when
did that when when did that that's
within the just the last 15 years of
everybody getting one that was netflix
you couldn't get you couldn't [ __ ]
get one right no no yeah if you got it
was hard to i tried to get with h i
tried to get i wasn't probably ready but
i tried to get an atrial special like in
the mid 90s
late 90s and then
um
you know my i think my show was on and
then i was watching somebody on hbo and
i said wow this [ __ ] got a
special [ __ ]
like i'm gonna [ __ ] call over there
but i was already on tv not be not
before i was on tv i didn't get one yeah
we didn't get out and get anything i
went to audition i never got a part of
the tv show
until i got my own show i never got a
[ __ ] special before i got my my own
tv shows the only thing i ever i even
auditioned for murphy brown as a
comedian and [ __ ] didn't get it
uh what's his name god bobby collins
and uh
so
it's like it's just years of [ __ ] no
years
decades of [ __ ] no
arsenio
you know
you know i've seen a show you love me
show me a lot of love now you already
all like we're still friends
yeah man we're still friends yeah no
he's a good dude man i i i back in the
day i would run into him when he was
working out sets at the ice house
so he's a good dude
and uh uh um what the [ __ ] is that you
hear that yelling kids they have kids
there's kids out there um
with the with the way that you work
right you're very meticulous about how
you prepare
well we both were that's one thing
that's one thing that's one of the uh
the connecting threads with you and i
had was because you would do a set or i
would do a set and i remember one time
sitting with you at the lab factory
i don't know if you remember man and we
were talking about writing and we were
talking about the process and you kind
of have that same old school
hey you write a joke you try it out if
it doesn't you change it you know and a
lot of the guys didn't have that work
ethic you know because it takes time man
it takes like i tell people to be up to
be a to do to be a comedian
you got to be willing to be by yourself
which is a hard thing and most people
you know like it's like playing a sport
people just want to show up on game day
and put on the uniform but what were you
when you were supposed to be practicing
nobody watching you you know writing and
and that that the comedy the joke comes
from the preparation where nobody's
cheering you on and and you're about you
got to be willing to be by yourself and
here are the things like and you said if
the people that are have trauma in their
lives a lot of times it's hard for us to
be by ourselves you know but you have to
fight through that it's i i i read this
book by uh stephen king and i think it's
called how to write or something i mean
he talked about oh on writing yeah right
not a great book
he gave a lot of his nuggets like like
gold nuggets on writing wait a minute
that [ __ ] was writing all about
people most throws and [ __ ] he wrote a
book about writing yeah yeah but he gave
away about how good was that word
that's a [ __ ] good word
one i've never heard
yeah but no but you know it uh it takes
discipline well how did you find that
book
uh because some you know what uh uh
somebody told me that
uh because i told you you're gonna be on
the podcast and they told me they saw
you
carrying a stephen king book yeah and i
said well why would [ __ ] will he be
preparing this
and it was the book about writing i'm
sure all right now it makes sense yeah
no i i always wanted
to get a a little little knowledge from
from from everyone and you know like as
far as like their how they created
something right you know and it comes
down and you know anybody had any art
you know
right what you did
as a cop man you didn't just go in there
you man you you know
you got people's experience sure they
shared knowledge with you exactly and
then you created your own persona right
exactly but but it came from people
sharing knowledge so the way i did is
you know uh i i would see how people
would go about their process right and
and then see if i can how much of that i
can have for myself and and i always
wanted to be that's right and you know
and i think this was important to you as
it was to me
um
was to be respected as a comedian
because there are a lot of comedians
that get no respect are like like this
[ __ ] right right that's right
oh man you know and me i just wanted
people to say [ __ ] that's a funny bit
right man where'd he come up with that
bit right you know like the way we
remember uh uh uh priors bits and
carlin's bits yeah about
carl's bit about stuff is like
[ __ ] amazing yeah and i i you know i
always wanted to be
that guy where people could could go
man and one of the things you can only
be that guy if you put your [ __ ]
hours like you know if you're if you're
if you're a boxer
and you're going to fight a year from
now
you're going to you're going to be away
from sex you're going to be away from
alcohol you'll be able to smoke you're
going to be by yourself you're going to
run in the morning and if you don't you
know who's going to know you're going to
know first and then everybody's gonna
[ __ ] know
because you're gonna get knocked out or
in the sixth round you're gonna hit a
wall and you gotta know that you're
gonna hit a wall like boxers but then if
you make it you get that second you see
those dudes come to come back and get a
second win but
if you don't prepare you you you can't
you you're not going to sustain you
can't [ __ ] do anything yeah even even
even if you got to the place where
somebody said hey man there's a thousand
people in there they're ready to go and
then you walk up there and you know that
you're not ready instead of saying no
dude i'm i'm cool i'm gonna go up there
and you go up there
but you're not
you're not connected to your own [ __ ]
you're not ready for the thousand people
and you go down so it's preparing
over and over and over and over for five
minutes i have a question for the both
of you you know when you do this stuff
you write you write your stuff and
you're by yourself
at what point in time do you write a
joke get it down or maybe a couple of
jokes and then present it to somebody
else
not the stage but just somebody else
nobody knows
to me the audience tells you whether the
joke's good or not because if i show
ground like what is it about this what's
that that's a joke i wrote
okay i don't think it i don't know i
don't know dude why would he say that uh
is it like so now you're in your head
you got doubt but let's show somebody
who doesn't know you and some crowd and
then yeah you see it work for me for me
as a process and i don't know i can't
write funny like i can't sit down and go
okay i'm gonna write a funny bit about
my son right i can't i gotta write first
the story that i'm thinking about like a
story of like you know when uh maybe you
wrecked a car and and i just write the
story first without like [ __ ] the funny
there's no funny in there it's just a
story now
and then i kind of stay away from it and
then i read it again
and now i make change you embellish you
you exaggerate you know you make you
want to you lie you you you know what i
mean
there's a joke i have about you know my
mom putting a cross over my my uh my bed
and the cross in real life that she put
over my bed was only like six seven
inches right yeah and didn't even have a
jesus it was just but in the joke the
cross is yeah four feet and and jesus is
is and she plugs it in jesus moves
around but that never happened but what
it was you know you exaggerate once you
do your writing that's when you your
exaggeration comes in
so that's that's my process i know we
all have i know kind of the same yeah i
never heard anybody say uh
that any comedians that i've known um i
heard years ago that jerry seinfeld used
to write for an hour a day but it didn't
have to be funny he just wrote
like you sit there and for an hour and
you're like i can't do it but you start
writing for two minutes yeah and then
you go to five minutes it's like it's
like if you were a runner then you go to
10 minutes and then all of a sudden it
starts to become easier and even though
like willie said it doesn't make sense
at that time you're just training
yourself to think about situations and
think about topics and think about
things but you're sitting down and you
are disciplining yourself enough to sit
for a [ __ ] hour after that when you
get to an hour get it then you can get
up and go
you know i told mayan years ago just
write for two minutes yeah and then
leave it alone and then try to write for
three minutes then write for five
and leave it alone
and then before you know it you can sit
down for 15 minutes you wouldn't even
know you'd be right for half an hour
yeah no i
i took this from seinfeld and i'm sure
you've heard it too you guys have heard
it where they asked him one time why he
wrote eight hours a day they asked him
and he said well one time i'm walking
around i was like he's walking around
new york and he goes hey a policeman
works eight hours he goes construction
guys working eight hours this lady's
here for eight hours
and that's where i started going wait a
minute i gotta put in
the uh you know this is my time in the
craft
but
the only thing for me man was uh was
that
was the networking part you know as
coming up matt if i i go back in time
and tell him that's really almost
it became the more important it became
almost
i was like
as important but [ __ ] man it just became
and if you're not a [ __ ] networker
yeah or you're not somebody that's going
to speak up
it's tough you put yourself in a tough
position but i'll tell you here's
another thing man which i i got
i feel like it's important especially
because you're here bro my son
is
actually i i love being a comedian i
mean there's nothing else
that gave me that high right that gives
you that high you know bro that rush you
get when you do a set and you [ __ ]
kill and you [ __ ]
to me
uh uh
him and my and my my boys i was their
coach for uh we started i started the
first travel team right and and
northeast l.a literally
it was yeah it was the first time that i
had told these guys from they're all
from frog all the kids i didn't pick
kids like like you would pick kids you
know
they were all from one neighborhood they
were all your homies right they're all
from frog town echo park silver lake all
the northeast kids and i would get and
and people that don't know explain where
frogtown is because uh it's elysian
elysian valley legion park is it called
is that over there yeah oh wait another
side this guy guy's going here the
[ __ ] thomas right
legion park
that's where it's at i don't know i call
it i know by his gag name right you know
yeah well frogtown that's an e that's a
city gang i work for the county side one
time i went to uh uh um
accompanies on sunset after a dodger
game and there was some cholo out there
with no t-shirt on he had ep on his
stomach i go huh what's up i thought i
was presley and he was like [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i said what's that i'll express
sorry man i don't know who you're where
the [ __ ] doesn't matter what you [ __ ]
told me to go [ __ ] myself
but i'll tell you padre is great though
you know i i i drank i used to drink it
uh with kenny landrieu back in the day
when kenny yeah can he like he doesn't
drink anymore but he hasn't drank for 10
years but this back in the day when he
would he was a dodger he'd stop in there
i guess no no he would go my house oh no
how come my house him and bible remember
bob oh yeah castillo yeah lincoln
heights taught fernando the screwball
yeah yeah so those guys man i i was able
because you know being comedians we it
was people that that start digging us
and we're getting vibes and i was always
a dodger fan i was and uh they they
would share information with me when
these guys were little
and they were telling me really man when
you because we started playing orange
county right all these little brown kids
we play orange county we play my friend
says willie if you uh if you want your
kids to to excel you've got to put them
in their in their in their toughest uh
uh competition and by the way his son
uh and and and he walked the walk and
you know because his son was uh they you
know kansas just won the the ncaa uh
championship uh
his uh and and basketball the the jedi
right right all right the uh oh i said
was a point guard uh remy remy martin
was uh his name was remy martin the
kid's remy yeah kids named randy yeah
well anyway this is this cognac yeah so
so i i took these guys to or i remember
the first time i just take you guys to
orange county you know and we would get
beat up by [ __ ] football scores right
27 to 2.
right
it'll be like you got a safety at least
no they're like you know yeah
thirty-something dude [ __ ] but
and then uh are the cats that i that uh
that i you know it's like comedy right i
always wanted to you know study the guys
that were really good you know
you know uh the guys you know i'm st you
know we always had guys uh that that
didn't leave that didn't leave the
neighborhood as far as communities yeah
they only play between pomona you're
right yeah all right
anyways uh i never asked those guys for
[ __ ] you know i asked i asked the guys
who were uh back in the day it was uh uh
dom herrera right when i was a young
comic yeah i would ask domino for help
like pick his brain he was right good
dude and the same thing i did with with
uh with baseball i would ask the guys
who play pro ball man you know i'm not
going to ask you know the drunk coach
from down the street so he would say
it's important that they look good it's
important that when they walk in
somewhere that they feel they belong
right so man
and when he put that in my head like it
makes sense even if we get beat up we're
going to look good so i remember
remember you guys had jackets
beanies you guys had your names on your
on their on their bags you guys had your
last names
and your numbers [ __ ] bro and jackets
and everybody matching cleats bro
everybody that we would walk in there
bro when when our team would walk in
with respect you know and little by
little we ended up beating chatsworth
bro right were you you know a chessboard
yeah yeah we when travel ball so
uh but but it so so so
yeah so you want to get respect you look
you have to look the part yeah and then
if you take enough [ __ ] beatings
right now you're [ __ ] taking beatings
you're like [ __ ] it you you you you you
fight back
so when i was a little league coach
uh
san fernando right in san fernando over
there like santa rosa league i had these
two brothers and the one brother was
good and then the other brother hector
looked like a little [ __ ] uh
ninja turtle like a big chest he was a
little kid he was the one that you you
didn't let play
so of course there's there's a uh um
ty runner on third and then the little
turtles up he's got the [ __ ] thing
and he's like you know the great gazoo
[ __ ] helmet the big ass you can't you
can't even see
back of the advisor's all the way back
here so i go and he was little
and i go
come over here put the [ __ ] you know
how the coach would put his hands on
your shoulder yeah so that you would
listen puts right here he's like listen
i look at him i go hector
don't swing
okay
don't swing whatever you do and you know
you ruined that kiss for life right you
know whatever you know every every every
big decision doesn't make it because i
ain't gonna do it
so you go i said i said you hear me i
gotta call me coach you gotta i gotta
have a coach
don't swing parker goes back there he's
like this [ __ ] swings at the first
one
i said hector
don't swing
takes a ball one and one he looks happy
he's all happy he's like
he's like
[ __ ] throw another one swings
together
throws another one ball two-two doesn't
know a ball
gonna kill me man
i said don't swing he swings
he [ __ ] nubs it
maybe three feet in front of home plate
swinging bun he's the swinging button
and he takes off running but he's like a
[ __ ] little turtle like a [ __ ]
little so he's running and it looks like
he's going to take him forever and the
pitcher comes around the catcher comes
around
picks it up
throws it
and pulls the first baseman off his back
foot foot comes off the base and [ __ ]
hector of course like he didn't slide he
kind of felt you know
like a domino
foul head first
and he was safe and that guy scored and
we won and
when he turned around to look at us he
had dirt on the visor
[Laughter]
and we picked them up and we carried
them around
i probably was never been
happier
i mean just [ __ ] amazing man like you
know baseball baseball did that yeah
that this little kid had a hero moment
after i told him don't [ __ ] swing
yeah you know and it was uh quite
special because well no you know what
two brothers and hours and they're
saying see holmes i told you you
shouldn't have swallowed the hector
[ __ ] heck they're all talking about
you brother after they're like bro don't
listen to him bro i don't listen to him
[Laughter]
but i mean that's you know i love i love
baseball baseball is uh
i think you played at san fernando right
i played san francisco what was your
position
i i uh let's see
i was a third baseman
uh the hot corner oh you can handle the
hot corner yeah i put everybody oh [ __ ]
and then that's not that's a no
that next the cat there's a ball the
balls is [ __ ] position bro we get
missiles [ __ ] that's what yeah that
was a [ __ ] pretty tough one look at
their basement in college right there
yeah right you [ __ ] but you know you
know how i got them uh good at [ __ ]
not getting out the way
i'd hit him tennis balls from like 15 20
feet away right
right all right
okay all right i learned all right i'm
sorry bro what do you have over your
head no no okay you can start doing that
so i was like all right come here come
here real quick come here real quick
tell
but hey bro if you need to mikey that's
all right no you could try uh children's
services can't get me for this right
tell them
how would i how would i hit yeah he
would he would uh okay he could he like
when i was like five but could do but
could he handle the bat like you could
throw it in here bro he would he could
hit it harder like twice as hard as he
as he could hit a baseball right now
like that oh [ __ ] but it wasn't until i
got to like high school was when he
started using tennis balls was like too
[ __ ] late all right
[Applause]
well you know what but i evolved i
evolved because because i i was gonna
kill them you know
you know and uh but i wouldn't get
tennis balls you're a dick bro
when i when in 10th grade after all the
uh
all the practice in the summer and the
beginning of the school you know and
then [ __ ] new year we have you
practice so i had a i had a bruise in
the ins right here in this hand right of
the glove hand so the back of my hand
was was purple
back here from the bruise and if i if i
went like that it it it would hurt to
the touch right there
so i went to the i went to the coach uh
and he was sitting at the desk and he
goes what can i do for you guys i said
hey man my hand is i don't know if i can
be able to play man my hands all [ __ ]
up he saw that it was purple he goes oh
yeah let me look at that yeah yeah oh
wow yeah he leans down
brings out a piece of foam that's just a
different like it's just a odd angle you
know odd size he gets a scissors
and he cuts a [ __ ] circle and he puts
it right here goes here you go let's see
out there [ __ ] 230
he just cut a pad to put in my glove
worthless yeah and was like no you know
and they sell those now no they make
them they're making for the inside yeah
i'm just curious did you listen
did you listen to your dad
follows instructions as a coach
did you believe it or would you believe
the other coach tell the truth no of
course you would tell the truth yeah i
mean
where would you get here come over here
and then i'll give you the reason
now did you believe if your dad said do
it this way do it that way or do this do
that did you follow his instructions or
if you had a second coach you're talking
to my time no what he did is uh he got
us uh uh like professional coaching when
we were like seven so he kind of like
stepped out of the way for
and let some other guy coach us but when
he would coach us like
no i wouldn't listen
and we would win bro
the reason i asked that i asked you if
you knew clint bonilla uh-huh clinton is
a retired homicide cop good friend of
mine he was coaching a team
that was he would just put the team
together
for the uh
these guys that go uh looking for pros
you know
scouts yeah they had a tournament back
in the midwest some place and he'd take
a team over there for the scouts
one of the guys on his team
was steve garvey's son well he had a lot
of them bro yeah
he had one that was playing first base
and and he told he told the kid he says
kelly she wouldn't believe people just
don't listen to their dads because i got
this first base right now he says
hey didn't your dad teach you anything
didn't your dad tell you he says yeah
but that's just my dad and it was steve
garvey's son who never listened to his
dad yeah so that's why you know if you
follow what your dad said well i'll tell
you i'll tell you something i used to
pay these guys a hundred dollars an hour
like his his fielding coach his batting
coach they're different guys man and
then and then they had their travel uh
team
and it would piss me off man because
they would be telling them stuff and
then i would drive home with them and go
hey and they're like hey dad you see how
he said that i go [ __ ] i've been
telling that for [ __ ] years
diligent but he's also very connected to
what he knows he just wants to write for
his son yeah but he wants the best for
like he read that book nobody's like he
reads that stephen king book you know
especially but he was he put together
shows in bars
he tried to help guys i mean there's
there's there's
what is the personality is like somebody
of like an organizer right
do you think we're gonna i think it's
like it's not somebody like i'm i was
solitary i didn't [ __ ] want to help
anybody i [ __ ] was working with like
a boxer you're gonna [ __ ] say i'll be
fighting you in two years let's hang out
together [ __ ] that [ __ ] i stayed away
from everybody
right now you did bro you did nobody got
to know me and i didn't talk to anybody
okay going back now going back on your
career obviously you've had an amazing
career bro but going back now uh i said
earlier how we can go back to and see
ourselves
would you go back and would you have
done anything different with with like
like how paul had that moment paul had
that moment of like
i could call it clarity like man we
should have
been more
of a group
with you guys that's exactly his words
bro he says me
and george we should all been more of a
group
what do you what do you
no no you keep it the way it is
no yeah i would have changed anything he
wouldn't have called me up
no no no but i mean you know i i think
that uh
you know he he he didn't set an example
for me i see that's bro so i never told
him that but i never told him that but
you know obviously you know it's we we
were talk about
comedies are a small community new to us
comedies are already a small community
now you get the latino community it was
tiny yeah so anything that happened to
anybody we all everybody [ __ ] you you
know like like you going on our senior
you know yeah uh uh you know uh paul
being on a million to one that's that
movie those things are big to us you
know
and uh and i always thought the reason
you were more of a
of a guy that would unite unite
everybody or was because of some things
that i heard
paul when you were coming up and he was
already headlining right he was already
paul and you were you you were you were
coming up behind him am i right yes and
he didn't show you the welcome mat like
look george man
uh
let me let me let me take you in and let
me and let me show you some things about
the craft about about just the business
in itself he never he never
let me tell you i'm going to tell you
something right now
that nobody knows
about our relationship okay
in the summer of 1979 he was already
starting to get pretty good
so
he told me
stand off to the side of the stage and
when i call you come up
okay where is it where is this at the
comedy store in westwood oh okay okay so
he goes up there i'm up there and he has
a jacket on and he's and he says come on
up here and i walk up there and he gives
me his jacket like i was a [ __ ]
ballet
and i walk off with the [ __ ] jacket
because i'm 18 with the [ __ ]
but it's [ __ ] embarrassing right but
you thought you were going to do stand
up i thought we would have i don't know
what it was i had no idea what it was
but you didn't think it was going to be
that i didn't think it was going to
pull me off
i've heard some stories of stuff that
that obviously
you know that it's only within the
comedy uh community bro
so
i i i i i kind of put it together why
you were the way you were it was kind of
like okay they didn't set the tone for
you so you were like all right [ __ ] it
this is the way it is and i grew up kind
of by myself anyways and then in in the
you know 1980
you know i was already doing 79 but i
wasn't around as much as like paul was
so paul was in the early 80s like 83-84
he was at the ice house and i show up on
a sunday i think he's there at a sunday
and
he sees me
while he's going into the green room and
he said i thought you died
so that's [ __ ] too i said oh
[ __ ] that's two oh there's that
comedian who died remember the number oh
he said it as an insult i thought you
died oh oh when you got off stage no
when i he hadn't seen me in a few years
oh so yeah i'm on a sunday hanging out
by the fireplace right yeah yeah he's
like hey i thought you died like that
was his [ __ ] joke oh so i was like oh
okay [ __ ] oh there was no there
was no
i really didn't
nothing personal i don't know the guy i
the only time i had seen paul was on
television stuff i hadn't seen him on
anything else
and i really didn't care for anything he
was that funny
and then i went and i saw him
do stand up one night and i thought he
was much funnier in stand-up than he was
on television i saw him one time i've
never bothered to see him again well
i mean
not the disparity but he didn't do a lot
it not a lot of
i mean he never had multiple tv shows he
had one that wasn't on that long but he
did some films and stuff and he had you
know some specials and stuff but you
know he's been around a long time around
40 years i mean yeah i've been around 40
years yeah
but you know i i know that's why i had
that question for you but i think yeah
and i think i think that that that's
that's true
uh but my personality was more
of a singular dude like i wasn't a
friendly guy yeah no bro i like i said i
i remember the the times that your
friend you know i remember the times
that we talked i remember one time you
and i were at the laugh factory we were
upstairs and we were watching uh jeff
garcia
and and uh you go hey willy isn't that
your joke you told me like that like i
don't want to talk i'll talk to him
later but you you you were
you did have that stickler like
uh
have respect for the craft kind of thing
yeah a lot of cats
yeah so
it's it's a passion and it's it's the
respect that that you want to have in
any career i guess whatever you do if
you want to if you [ __ ] build
you know your construction guy he wants
people to go yeah that's his wall man
well you know whatever right right um
but yeah you know if you if you were
what did this always ask me
what would have been your
aside from comedy what would have been
your dream job like a gig that you would
do if i could get for free not not not
no i want to be a [ __ ]
i would i would have been i would have
been a dirty cop i think i would have
i'm pretty sure no you're you're you're
pretty right on that one you could have
been shady yeah no man um
because i think about that situation
well but my dream job bro would have
been to coach uh coach baseball
at like maybe the high school level oh
wow that that would have been i mean
because you learn so much about the game
you learn how mental the game is like
there's a book called the mental game of
baseball written by this guy named
dorfman i think his last name is dorf
dorfman check it out and that guy was
scott boris he's you know scott boyce is
the biggest agent
baseball uh and and that was his
that guy would uh would would would um i
don't know be a therapist for his he
always had the 30 biggest picks uh uh
dorfman by the way harvey dorfman
harvard yeah and he wrote that that's a
great book man and when i started
learning about the psychology man and
and how i connected to life it actually
helped me in life you know i remember
my i remember this bro and i don't know
if we ever talked about it but he had a
really shitty they had taken him out he
was playing juco junior college and
ventura and he had a
bad games back to back to back right and
the coaches took them out and it was it
was really a bad situation because it
was a second year of junior college and
if you don't put up good numbers you're
not gonna get that ride that you want
for the four-year college sure so for
him to be sitting the pine and i
remember reading that book uh uh about
uh about the psychology of baseball
basically the psychology of baseball
and back in the day
he would have gotten the car
and uh and i would have said something
because oh they gave you in that bat
remember he gave you that bat and you
did something wrong and he yelled at you
and he said something like the [ __ ]
fabian
yeah that was the day i was there
that was the day i was there and i
remember they saying uh not to uh
if you're gonna have you're gonna help
your kid out don't bring it up don't
bring up the heirs right don't talk
unless he wants to right so i remember
that
that i i didn't i said don't say
anything don't bring it up don't say
[ __ ] because they brought him up in a
critical position
and it's hard not it's hard not to yeah
so he gets in the car uh he gets in the
car and all i said was like hey bro your
favorite food what is it man i was like
i knew what it was but i wanted him to
say he goes oh sushi
hey dude let's go grab some sushi gotta
go so we went we had sushi we had a
couple beers
bro we never talked about the gang i
think you said something and i let you
say something and i was just listening
yeah that went to a bunch of nobles and
then i got this book
you did no season like just changed what
book was it bro
remember
same thing
but check this out he uh
he got another at bat like two games
later
he hit a double and then hit doubles and
doubles and singles and then you're back
in the lineup then you got that ride to
san francisco right yeah that was it
that was it
yeah but it was but that day that when
he was [ __ ] the bed when he was
really [ __ ] up
is don't bring it up
because they say it's a thing they say
uh and to their dads out there that have
their kids in school they say it's a
psychological choke like you're actually
choking them psychologically because the
players already know they're [ __ ] up
you know the pl the other team knows the
coach knows they're [ __ ] right
and so they they they so now you get in
the car with them and you get in this
car where it's a little compartment and
now
you're doing extra choking you know like
now they got nowhere to go mentally to
release that [ __ ] so it was just like we
we weren't talking about nothing but
but sushi man that's all the book was
probably how to get your dad to take it
to sushi
but you see that that
in in those books like i i guess you
look at books to to look at uh my only
education is my only education george
you know my only education
you know when we were at the we were
doing the taping
she had a a line where
she didn't finish the line and she
paused and i said it over
her line because i'll go like yeah right
you can't we can't be leaving right and
she's and they come back and goes oh she
had a line there her coach said i said
hey well she's gotta she's gotta pick it
up man like i'm not gonna wait around
for her to whatever she felt is a decent
enough pause because she's a little bit
haven't been doing it as long
she doesn't know that you could you know
you can go ahead and you don't have to
pause
an unnatural conversation so i jumped in
there a couple of times
and i said hey you know pick it up pick
it up you're coaching pick it up yes and
pick it up like get to it yeah
i so you're you're
you got two girls only one yeah one girl
okay
two personalities though
but i mean listen i mean to start out
doing comedy and wanting to be a
comedian my whole life and then have and
being an only child and then having
every child everybody always talks about
you being an only child brother they say
hey the reason george is like that
because he's only [ __ ] never shared
his toys
i never know how to share [ __ ] toys
that's true so so i i always thought
that was one of the reasons that you
were to me i think it's a big i i
wouldn't say that
having that personality of being
singular
and away from everybody is the best way
to approach [ __ ] life
you know
because your relationships are very
you know we we come in and out so
you know we're there for a week then we
leave to another place and then if
you're growing if you grow up and people
are you know leave you it's the perfect
[ __ ] job for somebody who's used to
being left yeah you leave you know yeah
so in relationships you would say well
i'm gonna i'm gonna leave before you
leave
all right and then it doesn't serve you
as a person it serves you in this
business because if you're nervous
you're so used to having bad [ __ ] happen
you block it out it's not gonna
yeah you're not gonna crumble because
you're so nervous no for for me and for
young comics out there and i'll give
this advice to young comics out there
that work the road because you know man
anybody that works the road
and i don't care how tough you say you
want to act is lonely bro because you
get on the airplane you go you go by
yourself you go to that hotel or that or
or by yourself and then you get to the
show and there's people that like you
people that recognize you show's over
now you're by yourself again
and and [ __ ] 22
like you know and then the next like you
said the next week another city
and and and me
obviously i found uh an answer drinking
right i would drink
more than the average guy to get through
it for me
you know and then as i got older and i
start and i i felt like
hopefully a little wiser i started
thinking wait a minute my life my life
is not the norm you know i don't have a
regular family regular friends i said
that guy i'm gonna visit uh you know in
texas this week
that guy even though i see him once a
year that guy's actually like family to
me that's but i just don't have
a regular we don't have a regular uh uh
type of uh relationships so i made those
guys
i opened up myself where i go wait a
minute that's my friend that's i'm gonna
even though i'm only here for a week so
that's how i cope with it right and i'm
sure you had your your way was to just
say [ __ ] it right i don't wanna i'm
gonna get close to people
and because i would run into people that
would be hurt
because you wouldn't call them the next
time you went to that city oh yeah yeah
i would meet guys and they're like man
we went to go we went to go drink and
[ __ ] he didn't even turn my calls all
right bro you know
it was your will it was your way
everybody copes right everybody copes
their own
my way and i did that for a long time
until i said all right [ __ ] i you know
uh let me find a different a different
way to to to make this work for me the
road yeah are you still out there right
yeah bro i'm still yeah and and how is
it different now
for me uh
i don't know you still drink or you
don't drink yeah absolutely i drink bro
yeah um
no i i
i enjoy it more now as we get older we
get wiser right when you're when you're
when you're you're a young comic you're
just you're you're a [ __ ] crazy
cowboy man you know what i mean you're
you're [ __ ] a you're out there
just [ __ ] wildest while it can be man
drinks are free drinks for free
yeah
yeah
everywhere so
it's almost like if you were a lion and
the waitresses were like little uh you
know yeah
which one
yeah which one this week yeah
it is yeah you know how bad you know how
bad i was in 1991 i went to work before
i did the tonight show i went to work in
atlantic city
in the in a club and uh and and this
waitress came over the first night and
she goes i just want to let you know i
suck everybody's dick at the end of the
week all the
headliners i said oh okay i'll see you
sunday then
thanks for the heads up i was so bad she
left before
that's where the guy said where's that
girl
you meet a girl and they would tell you
they would they would give you the
lineup like you know i was with george
you know i was with paul you know i was
a carlos
i would hear that and i'll be like what
the [ __ ]
i'm the fourth one in what the [ __ ] you
know
but yeah
well for me bro as i got older as a and
and i uh
i've learned to enjoy
uh things that i didn't enjoy before you
know and
and and enjoy the craft a lot more
everything slows down as you get older
yeah
it does and you it's just enjoy i mean
i'm not not ready to die or retire or
anything but but it's just a lot more
fun now like before it would be okay
let's say okay i'll give you an example
let's say there's a comedian before
and and i didn't pick the guy i didn't
pick the opener and i'm like [ __ ] i
didn't pick this guy man that's what the
[ __ ] all right
now it's like okay you got you got an
opener cool what's his name all right uh
harry harry derry okay harry dave right
whatever right and then like and then i
watch them [ __ ] good too
yeah so
so the guy does like hacky jokes and and
i just i now i just smile
you know now i just smile go oh this guy
he's got a lot to learn you know and
then he'll get off and it was like hey
did you see me yeah man what'd you think
dude man keep at it you know keep
working you know whereas before i'd be
like the [ __ ] are you doing man you
[ __ ] hack i didn't even [ __ ] pick
you man [ __ ] i used to be you know
nah now that that's out i don't report
you know darren carter right yeah i
remember before darren carter was my
feature one time and oh my god i was
such an [ __ ] to him man
and i was like what the [ __ ] you doing
with all these noises and just [ __ ]
did you tell some [ __ ] jokes man
you know i was i looked and that was
it's just and it became a style like a
creative yeah a style of comedian that
does the noises and little dances yeah
so what is he the freckled face yeah
he's a mexican
yeah
he's a gangster he does he does that
yeah yeah no he's guys i'll be right
back
yeah no he's easy you know i handle
things different now you know i i would
embrace that that comedian that
you know what i mean that would that
would otherwise uh you know other times
would piss me off no i'd be like
you know it could work man i'm glad i'm
glad you're doing your thing
you know i followed comedy you know for
you first
first standup live comic i saw was uh
dom herrera
yeah and and i saw him and he was
hilarious to me i've always followed com
i've always followed i listen to you all
the time all the
these guys i do
uh to be
working or hanging around or whatever
whatever it is we're doing well you know
it's funny but there's a there's a big
connection with comedians and cops and
people
people have asked like how come
any city i go to bro i always hang out
the cops always they'll call me whether
you're in town yeah all right boom boom
and
i feel that the connection between
comedians and cops
is because you guys your sense of humor
is dark as [ __ ] oh yeah the jokes
are here the jokes that these guys tell
yeah are just i remember a buddy of mine
a homicide detective and now they want
to go see we went to go party after
right but they went to go see a crime
and then
and he goes he goes uh
he goes i go what happened to that guy
and he goes he goes he was shy i go what
do you mean shy no he was all red
he shot himself in the face and the blow
was all over so the cops joke was yeah
he was shy you know
he was out he was blushing and that was
a blessing
yeah he killed himself but that was that
was that's cop humor yeah yeah you have
to have a sense of humor
in order to get through all the [ __ ]
that we you see and deal with family so
you have to have a morose sense of humor
and i and i believe that's the
connection between why so many cops uh
and comedians there's a there's a
there's the connection man right
because
the dirtier the funnier the far off i
laugh harder
hey bro and but amongst musicians
there's more camaraderie than there is
amongst comedy you've been around
comedians yes yeah so he played he
played music yeah there there was
everybody everybody gets along
everybody's trying to help everybody out
it's different there's nothing wrong
with somebody jumping in there and doing
a set with you right you know somebody
wants to come in here did you play when
you played with the salas brothers i i
remember when they were the solas
brothers i remember when they were the
solos brother before they became
yeah yeah they were cute they were young
oh really yeah you used to see them
no there's a catholic church right there
in east l.a
but equal part by the by the cross
street from the from the lake
no no that's that's a that's a police
station across from the lake right on
atlantic boulevard right by this
public's uh pool okay there's a
catholic school there
and that's first first place i saw him
play so you guys no there is like george
is saying there is more of a there is
more of a
of a brotherhood sure because uh what
about uh the drummer for uh for war cell
cell
you know no i don't know okay
good dude right dude
but also but also
you have the brothers and oasis that
don't talk yep uh and van halen the
singer and the and eddie van halen kevin
that didn't
don't didn't vibe so you could get some
[ __ ] really hard [ __ ]
relationships and music where
rudy and steve didn't talk for a long
time they were not they they went to the
grave not talking well they were talking
just before they went to the grave they
did yeah
yeah i know but they were there was
always battle with those two yeah and
then you go and then i would see them
and then i they even made two [ __ ]
theaters
right so so so
i mean if you look at
their brotherhood like whatever business
they
had with each other or whatever issues
they had with each other the business
drove those a wedge to those guys that
family couldn't put together yeah that
went years later
without talking yeah that was family
problems though but if thierry was
playing and somebody from the
midnighters was in the house hey come on
up play set with us they get up there
and play with them right you know what
it is yeah you play with those guys yeah
i played with themselves so it didn't
matter uh you know los lobos i saw him
at the greek theater last year and i i
want to say they had
those lonely boys or one of them
and
one of the guitar players they let him
jam with the lobos
and
he was so excited because he was up
there playing they didn't care you know
he's up there playing
and
the los lobos conrad was laughing at him
because he's telling the other guy hey
look at this look at this guy you know
he's so excited just because he's up
here jamming with but it didn't matter
you can jam with anybody when you're a
player right yeah and yeah george i'll
come out you
but comedians you do stuff on your own
so you don't want somebody to get up
there i thought you went like this
i thought this comedian
where did they come from
like like in the early 80s
it was angel salazar was in new york
and then
there was a guy named hank garcia who
did the tonight show in the 70s fluffy
came out in the 80s no was he around the
80s yeah
long time ago
no fluffy floyd didn't come out until 80
or early 90s because i used to hire him
i hired him right there at stephen's
steakhouse yeah but but that was the no
no brooke
i had started in 91
and he he hadn't started yet
he hadn't started comedy yet he would
have been 14 in 1990 so probably early
yeah 90s at some point if he now he's
46.
oh yeah yeah he's younger than i thought
yeah yeah he's
yeah young
i remember hiring uh him then
alonzo bowden
that's why i did all my fundraisers for
these guys
rescue that's right he was part of the
crew
uh jim you know jim jimmy phillippi
right he's a good guy he's a great guy
good friend of mine he has a really good
i'm not going to say him but man he's
got some good mob stories oh yeah he
does
he wanted me to do one of his he wanted
me to do one of the interview with
uh mobster but the guy
that you're talking about didn't want a
cop doing it you know yeah okay when i
when he when he told me this guy
knocked that you know the story yeah
when he went looking for him and they
said such-and-such is here to see you
heavy-hitter bro i'll tell you after
yeah i don't want to you know yeah
uh
that though i don't want to drop any
names no no no no
somebody if you said his name every
other affiliation is not important
it would be
everybody
yeah um but yeah he's got some really
good stories man a good good guy we'll
tell the story what happened don't say
his name but they're not going to do it
and then said hey i just i i came here
looking for you to tell you that i knew
your dad real well
and your dad was had a lot of respect
well known and i just want to tell you
man the message is that your dad was a
well-liked guy and i just felt like i
had to tell you that that's what he told
me do you hear
that and he was going to do
a one-on-one show one-man show with this
guy yeah and he wanted me to be the
moderator wanted me to do the interview
and the guy said we got to find somebody
else because i just can't work with cops
you know he didn't really yeah that's
real he didn't want me
you know and just still didn't have the
faith and that was all good uh but he
was a heavy hitter and jim and i are so
so great friends i was at uh whisper
rock in arizona playing golf
with these guys uh and uh this little
guy came in italian doing a stocky dude
he's got the chain he's got a big watch
and they go hey there's scotty over
there scotty
[ __ ] scotty because a's you guys
what's going on hey he goes what let me
see your watch oh let me see that enjoy
that oh god i thought that was a for
gazing from over there it looked like it
was a [ __ ]
god bless i'm like who's that oh scotty
that [ __ ] was a [ __ ] mobster
for the witness [ __ ] relocation
program
he changed his name with scotty
about that one
relocation so so
did you guys know you guys know each
other
no man i well i thought i did the
fundraiser i for 15 years i did
fundraisers there bro that's what i'll
that's all i did i was working homicide
at the time i used to put on fundraisers
for
homicide bureau and for the national
latino peace officers association so we
we
i'm sure we crossed we've crossed bro uh
jim jim uh he always helped me out with
uh with the fundraisers for the for the
kids sure he would give me that homey
discount you know like because i would
have dinner for the the par the parents
and then we would have a comedy show
yeah and obviously all the money went to
these guys to the teams pretty good one
of the coolest things that
remember uh when the whole two teams
that there was like 30 kids all you guys
walked into dicks
remember that dick's sporting goods and
what did you guys do bro
whatever you want
everybody every little kid bro there
were kids picking up like two baseball
gloves can i get two coach i say yeah go
two two
holy [ __ ] right
that's 500 bro that's 500 bucks two
gloves yeah and then another kid will
grab a [ __ ] pants and
i remember it would have catchers gear
catchers get your coach i said get it
kid i felt like honestly
yeah it is a great feeling bro and it
wasn't i don't you know it wasn't just
because of me it was all the people who
when i would put a flyer out you know oh
that's stevens and they would come and i
would always put hey man this money is
going
to a good cause you know and uh it does
you feel like santa claus bro you know
and here's another thing i'll tell you
what i felt really good when like three
or four of your friends in high school
where they wrote the story meal
oh yeah
come here come here bro tell the story
real quick
this is the one that makes me feel good
like the payoff you know to me yeah like
so
what what did uh
what did they what did your like three
or four friends did no yeah so like you
know when you go to college you got to
take the sats and like write a essay
and the topic was like i write someone
who really impacted your life
and then like uh two of my friends came
up to me without even like you know just
writing like separately throughout the
day hey bro i just want to tell you that
i wrote about your dad and i really
really changed it and yeah like um i'd
say
maybe
six or seven of my friends who played
who i played literally with ended up
playing uh college baseball too
it's kind of crazy yeah i know no way no
it's always you know it was an effort
community effort man it was it was i
can't say that because it was the other
coaches that helped it was the parents
that would help me put together bro i
did this thing
i i i created this thing in the
summertime and we did it at lapd at the
uh academy because one of the kids was
uh his dad was a cop
and we he let us use the front yard you
know the lawn in the front right there
once you go in there's the lawn right
there
and bro do you know that we snuck in
beers and we we would sell them
we would sell the beers like there was
eight dollars of beer
and uh and then
one mom was was in charge of bringing a
big pot of rice another mom uh the beans
another mom the tortillas all right and
the plates cost to make it it was um if
you put it on you know on paper it's
probably 50 60 bucks right 70 bucks but
everyone that came and wanted to play
had to pay 50 bucks bro for that for
that meal right a little little
carnosaur meal bro yeah and and we've
turned that money around and
there you go no
but that goes to the personality right
of wanting to be an includer and wanting
to make people better around him the
kids around him and and jimmy doesn't
like the notoriety he doesn't want
people no no he doesn't we we did the
same thing
uh bought high school rings for the kids
[ __ ] starts [ __ ] warrants that's
probably why
for the garfield high school don't bring
me up
don't bring me up yeah they want to do a
press conference he says absolutely not
you know we don't want to because they
won the championship we got them rings
uh we got within each ring was 500 of
pop yeah yeah and i forget how many
rings they wanted to buy i said ching
god we're not buying for the whole
school right right but you know the
staff the clarity the debt that
and he got it all and that's he's a real
community guy yeah even though and i
didn't know until i heard started
hearing those mob stories of like one of
the oldest italian families in uh like
east l.a area is his dad when they came
from
sicily it was yeah
yeah that was a different uh area in the
back end when it's in the 50s 40s
it's a drink uh with his dad oh really
yeah
and jim's the same way as his dad was
funny sharp
sharp top yeah yeah quick man okay give
us the update on the bfw
vfw we're still waiting for them to
reopen again it's still administrative
work they're catching up on them we just
had a meeting the other day
and so i'm telling you what happened
administratively you know
vfw post 1944 was over in oceana heights
and they were closed down there was
administrative paperwork that had to be
done and everything has to be done it's
a 501c3 thing so administrative there is
no
uh
investigation there's no malfeasance
nobody's stealing anything it's one of
them they make money at that post
but administratively their paperwork was
gone one of the things that was gone uh
their taxes weren't paid well the taxes
were paid and they were paid on time but
they didn't get posted because
they're listed as the veterans of
veterans of foreign wars post 1944
la puente well they wrote vfw
instead of veterans of foreign wars
that's enough to kick it back until they
get everything legitimized and in fact
they've they realized that yeah they had
been paid matter of fact they owed
us money
back so it's administrative work they're
trying to catch up on everything
reporting properly you know where did
you spend your money where's this gone
was it
and so we're hoping beyond hope that by
the end of this month we're back in
business again
and and i go down there god bless once a
week
once a week every tuesday you haven't
been in there lately right no no it's
close
door's locked like a chain on them like
insulting there's three guys that we
meet and so now we're going over to uh
we go to some place i'll find once a
week find a place to have a cocktail
matter of fact this uh at rudy's right
there behind pep boys in east l.a yeah i
know exactly that so we're gonna go down
there and have lunch uh with some guys
on tuesday
i don't know
and and what what are they doing they do
any shows in there any music
at the vfw yeah oh yeah yeah they they
have uh shows uh the legends uh
legends of east l.a
uh put on concerts there they made
nighter shows who the legends would be
like
oh
guys like well tiara used to play
uh rocky padilla used to play
lou satins would get together up there
and play
uh the big guy is frankie and i can't
remember frankie's last name i'm sorry
frankie what about rosie and the
originals uh
she's no but she's been she's played it
at stevenson is she chicano is she no no
no oh i always that's you
i won't say i would say no i i don't
think so okay i always thought she was
because she was from uh
from the east side right yeah
they put on big shows shows that unlike
when you perform there they put on shows
there they four thousand people they
close off the front street use the front
street put up a big stage it's a big
thing there now no no they do they have
they they don't do that anymore they do
that there's somebody i think that's
what they're doing
uh some uh latino group
i don't know if it's just that because i
don't follow him that much you know hey
i i go down there to eat and do whatever
somebody that i like he'll tell me hey i
got this group coming in so we go down
and
uh i'm trying to go out there
so he has vicki carr often vicki carr
i've seen i've been down there vicky
carr was good friends with his mom and
dad for the 25th winter which vickie
carr was at at their house i was out
there with them they said steven's they
gonna have it on the website
yeah they they put it on their website
everybody's gonna watch uh
all i've seen lately are
are
latino groups coming up
well what else would you put out there
so if your place ever opens
we'll go in there and do a show
you you you he he he's told me
he's having all right
it will get somebody else but not rudy
moreno
doesn't have to be rude keep walking
what about rudy moreno
i don't know what to say
you know what he's so desperate to sell
tickets he's putting [ __ ] there's
noodles out there chicks that are naked
he and you're like whoa what's this what
the [ __ ] rudy's gonna be somewhere
tuesday night the [ __ ] is false
advertising he got he put smoking a
chick with a bikini hey bro i know the
camel toe let's say you're like what the
[ __ ] wait
yeah he's a
man you you know him bro
i think you've known him longer than i
ain't the character bro he's uh
what about when he fell in the fire man
i don't know he fell hand he got he got
drunk and he fell into a little barbecue
pit
hands first so he burned it he burned
his hands like the skin of his hands so
you had to wear these mittens
socks because you know [ __ ] little
white hands yeah like like a cat a
little mittens on it
well the only chicago make
my favorite story is like he used to get
paid x amount of money for this to book
this casino uh
converse yeah and then
he'd handle he'd handle the comedians
he's 20 bucks you know he can like you
know give some you know that start you
know i know you know what what do you do
here keep all the money yeah bro uh
he's still out there i think he's still
out there trying to
yeah but i think i don't i don't really
talk to him too much bro no you know
he's still doing stand-up he's still
doing
i get his advert i get his stuff so he's
out do you see how he's using girls now
like inappropriate pictures to try to
sell comedy tickets no
i don't pay attention
entertaining bro because he'll say he'll
say things like uh
he'll say hey everybody come support me
in my club all these years that i've
done comedy for you guys you guys don't
come support me all right whatever
although those are his commercials so
those are those that's him inviting
people to his comedy shows you know what
after all the years and all the shows
i've done and you can't come see my show
okay we know we know i know where my
friends are and that'd be the end of the
video and then they say come see me at
you know
something
at go bananas yeah go bananas
well i hate to be time cop guys but
that's uh two hours 15 for us what the
[ __ ] yeah that's that's goodbye
here's a gofundme for what
first jaguar
you gotta tune up hey willie man thanks
for coming in dude thank you for having
me that was awesome man thanks for
coming i learned a lot about you i
didn't know and uh i don't i can't
remember that we talked that much but
[ __ ] i'm glad we talked today no right
on bro and it's good i'm glad you
solidified what i
what you you know you coming and and
sharing about
your situation
of why you were kind of a little
disconnected from everybody so i you
know i get it i get it bro yeah thank
you for having me brother for having me
guys thanks for coming out thank you man
thank you
you